Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
You posting a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike in the whole system.
After I saw my buddy Kevin Rose,
I've known him forever,
some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him,
I said,
dude,
you look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing Peloton five days a week now.
That caught my attention because Kevin does nothing five days a week and you
know,
I love you Kevin,
but it really peaked my curiosity,
ended up getting a system and it's become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually,
but peloton is an indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting classes into your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite class on demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do live
classes and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions that are shorter,
like 20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone seems to have
their favorite instructor or you can select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that that along with the real time leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller than you would expect so it can fit in
a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not,
and it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you say ma accessories,
wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and those are in the accessory category.
So there's $100 off is a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else or are you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories including the shoes that you all want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code Tim.
Yeah,
this episode is brought to you by wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my go to platform for blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for everything every day.
My site tim.blog is built on it.
The websites for my books,
including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors.
It's all in wordpress.com and the founder Matt Mullenweg.
One of my close friends has appeared on the show many times.
Just search Matt Mullenweg,
Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a personal blog,
a business site,
or both,
you can make a really big impact right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good company.
It's used by the New Yorker,
Jay Z,
Beyonce,
five 38 tech crunch,
Ted,
CNN,
and time just to name a handful.
And one of my friends@googlewhoshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com
offers the quote best out of the box SEO imaginable end quote.
And it's one of the many reasons that nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of designs and templates that you can use and it's easy to
get started.
There's no need to worry about security upgrades,
hosting any of that there for 24 seven support.
And they're very,
very responsive.
If you have questions,
they get right back to you.
And this allows you to create the highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction.
So if you're building a website,
period,
when my friends come to me and ask what I use,
what I recommend they use,
the answer is wordpress.com so check it out.
Do you want to get started today?
Learn more with a 15% discount off any new plan.
Go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to create your website and find the plan
that's right for you.
So learn more.
Take a look,
wordpress.com forward slash Tim for 15% off a brand new website.
Check it out.
Yeah.
Hello boys and girls,
ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers of all different types across
all different industries and areas of expertise.
And this episode we have Jason Freed on Twitter at Jason Freed,
F R I e d base camp.com.
He is the cofounder and CEO of base camp,
previously known as 37 signals,
a Chicago based software from the company's flagship product base camp,
which I've used for many,
many years is a project management and team communication application trusted by
millions.
He's also the coauthor of getting real subtitle,
the smarter,
faster,
easier way to build a successful web application which is available for
free@gettingrealdotthirtysevensignals.com.
He's also the coauthor of the New York Times bestseller rework and remote
subtitle office not required.
There's also a new book coming soon.
It doesn't have to be crazy at work and you can actually thread those together
to tell a lot of this story.
Jason writes a regular column for ink magazine and is a frequent contributor to
base camps.
Popular blog.
Popular is an understatement.
Signal versus noise which offers quote strong opinions and share thoughts on
design,
business and tech and quote.
Yeah.
Jason,
welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me Tim.
And we have,
we have treated so many email over the years and uh,
certainly met on a,
on a handful of occasions and you have to be one of the most requested guests
for this podcast.
So thrilled that you were able and willing to make the time.
So many thank you to everybody who wanted to hear me.
I don't know why,
but it's great to hear that I'm wanting,
well I think part of why people like to hear from you,
and maybe it's a love hate thing,
but I think that what you said to me before we started is indicative.
So one was in response to what I always say to guests and that is you have final
cut.
So it's better to kind of go a little over the edge and we can pare it back
later.
And you said,
actually,
I don't want that much control,
whatever I say,
I should go out into the world in effect a is what you said.
And,
and you are known for being very raw and Contrarion,
uh,
which,
which I think has great appeal to a lot of people,
particularly in the current climate that we don't need to describe for everybody
to understand.
And I'll start given that with a quote from Jeff Bezos,
the trillionaire in the making behind Amazon quote,
Jason is immune to dogma and has much to teach in 37 signals.
He has built an elegant company with elegant products based on the idea that
less is more.
Now,
of course this is before we went from 37 signals to base camp.
But I,
I'd love to talk about this,
this immune to dogma component and we could certainly talk about less is more.
Jeff ended up investing in your company,
which is a whole separate story that we've,
we've covered in some respects with the conversation I had with uh,
your,
your partner in crime DHH separately.
So we won't dig into that.
But what I'm really curious to know is this immune to dogma ability to question
assumptions.
How much of that is an innate skill versus an acquired skill?
Um,
I guess it's hard for me to say from where I sit,
but I think a big part of it is that I don't really pay attention to a lot of
things actually.
So,
um,
maybe I have different points of view because I haven't heard the other ones or
I,
I have different points of view because I haven't let,
you know,
society's norms and the general point of view get into my head.
So I have to come up with my own ideas.
I've always sort of,
I pay attention to some degree,
but I'm,
I'm pretty oblivious to a lot of things intentionally cause I,
I don't want to be influenced that much.
And it's one of the reasons why I don't read industry news.
I read very little news in general,
but I definitely don't read industry news.
I don't want to know what everyone else is doing.
Um,
I find it's very easy to end up following and being like everybody else when
you're constantly hearing what everyone else has on their mind,
it's very hard then to fight against that.
So by not filling my mind with other people's ideas,
I have nowhere to go but to follow my own.
And I think that perhaps that's why I'm,
I'm immune to to dogmas.
That's just don't even pay attention.
You just don't have as much exposure on some attentional.
Yeah.
What are,
what are some of the parameters or rules for yourself,
structures,
systems,
anything that you've put in place to find that sweet spot of deliberate,
selective ignorance,
so to speak?
Yeah.
Uh,
um,
a lot of it is just kind of going with the flow and not having,
I don't have a lot of structure,
for example.
Um,
I,
I don't have routines.
Uh,
I don't,
uh,
I don't have any goals.
I've never had any goals.
Goals are not something that I,
I pay attention to.
Um,
I just sort of do a,
what I feel like is the right thing to do in any given situation.
And I don't,
I don't look longterm at things other than I want to.
Like for example,
being in business over the long term,
I'd like to live over the long term.
I'd like to be nice and getting better over the long term,
but I don't have the goalposts along the way.
Um,
so because of that and because they don't have much of a,
of a routine,
I sort of just take it as it comes.
And,
uh,
I think that also perhaps allows me to sidestep a lot of the ways you're
supposed to do things,
you know?
And because I don't plan to,
because I don't think too far ahead on any individual one thing.
Um,
I,
I just able to sort of go where I need to when I to,
uh,
and I know that's,
it's,
it's funny because I'll talk to a lot of people about this.
Uh,
and people would come on,
you must have some goals,
like,
you know,
this or that.
And I really,
really don't have any,
I can't remember ever having one eye.
I just do the best I can in any given situation and that's the best I can do.
And however that ends up playing itself out over time is how it ends up playing
itself out over time.
I,
I don't want to measure up.
Uh,
one of my favorite quotes is,
um,
Gosh,
I forget now who it is.
Um,
maybe it's Mark Twain,
but you know,
he's probably said everything or
everything's attributed to him,
but,
um,
it could,
it could have been,
it could have been able Lincoln.
Yeah.
Reinstein one of them,
right.
Um,
uh,
basically comparison is the death of joy.
And uh,
I love that quote because,
uh,
it,
it comes down to people,
it comes down to situations and it also comes down to goals and setting goals.
For me,
um,
I don't want to compare myself to an idea I had two years prior,
you know,
of where I wanted to be.
I don't know where I'm going to want to be in two years.
So to set a goal that's long term,
in some cases you're actually setting it for,
you know who you are when you set it versus who you are when you're going to get
there.
And that's something that a friend of mine told me once and I thought that a guy
named Jim Coudal who I thought was just,
it's a wonderful quote.
I don't know if it's his or someone else's,
but it really rang true.
And so that's kind of how I,
how I go about the world.
Well,
let's,
let's look at that in a real world example because this is,
this is something that is,
I'm sure you've experienced as you noted,
people react to with a certain level of disbelief,
right?
You have a s a profitable company,
17 out of 17 years or now what I read maybe out of date,
but however many years out of however many years.
And,
uh,
you have an organization,
you are successful certainly by almost any objective measure.
What did the last week look like?
We're recording this on a Thursday afternoon,
so we're coming up to the tail end of what most people would consider a business
week.
Uh,
and if you don't have goals,
you must have some means of making better decisions versus shitty decisions.
Uh,
so could you maybe walk us through what this week has looked like for you?
How you've spent your time,
which I know is very broad,
but we perhaps use that as a launching point.
Yeah,
this week is a little tricky cause I had some personal stuff I had to deal with
in the beginning of the week,
so it will take like a week before or something like that.
Perfect.
Um,
so,
you know,
at base camp we work in,
um,
what we call six weeks cycles.
So we are,
we don't work on anything.
Okay.
I'm generalizing,
but for the most part,
we don't work on anything that takes longer than six weeks to do.
So,
um,
our goals technically are to deliver something great within six weeks,
whatever we're building.
Um,
as a,
as an organization,
that's sort of where our goals are,
but are,
I don't have personal goals.
Like I don't have a goal.
Like,
if we,
I,
we don't set personal goals,
we don't say company wide goals in terms of uh,
like this feature will be successful if or uh,
you know,
if it brings in this amount of money it'll be worth it or anything like that.
Um,
our,
our goal if you do want to use the word is just to do the best job we can.
So last week I met with a couple of teams who are doing some projects and kind
of reviewed them with them and tried to help them through some problems,
work through some ideas.
We're just finalizing some,
some um,
some stuff on our books.
So I'm working on the book that we're,
we're finishing,
our manuscript is due in a couple of weeks,
so I did some of that.
Um,
but,
but really it's all about what we're actually doing at the moment versus sort of
the big picture as to why we're doing it other than we just want to do a good
job.
We have an idea,
we've set out,
set out some work we're going to do over the next six weeks and just helping
people get there.
And do the best we can and also make decisions and cut things and say we can't
do all these things we want to do.
What's the important part of this?
So I love trying to get to what's the most important part of something versus
you know,
we don't have any,
for example,
we don't have any KPIs at base camp.
We don't have key performance indicators.
Yeah,
I didn't even know what that meant by the way until recently,
cause I kinda heard everyone talking about them.
I'm like what do we have those?
And they go,
oh no,
we don't have the,
we don't.
Just to pause for a second.
So for people who are like what tps reports,
so Kpis,
KPIs are referred to very often in startup vernacular,
particularly in the tech world as key performance indicators,
which refer to the few or handful of metrics that are prized and most valued
within your company.
And that that could be revenue per employee.
It could be a monthly unique users or any number of other things.
Week on week growth of x.
Who knows?
So sorry to direct,
but just for people who don't come from that world,
she's so you don't have Cape Cape Kpis
don't have that.
We don't have revenue growth number targets.
We don't have,
we don't want to talk.
Okay.
So we don't have goals that we don't have targets,
we don't have KPIs,
we don't have um,
sort of those kinds of reasons for doing what we do every day.
Uh,
the reason we do what we do everyday is because we enjoy doing it and we want to
make what we're working on better and we're making the thing that we're making
for others.
We're also making for ourselves.
So we technically want to make our own tooling better because it helps us do
better job with what we do.
So it really is this day to day or week to week or every six weeks sort of
rolling thing where you,
you,
you set out some stuff you want to do,
you do it the best you can at the end of those six weeks.
We take a week or two off from scheduled work and we do other things at work.
We roam around and have new ideas,
play with some stuff,
and then we pick another set of products that do over the next six weeks.
And we just kind of go as we go and course correct as we go.
And we just don't have any of these big,
big picture of things.
So my weeks look like feedback,
my weeks look,
look like thinking they look like writing.
Sometimes it requires me to debate things with people.
Um,
uh,
you know,
to,
to lay out,
uh,
some,
some reasons for why we're doing things,
but my week is,
is not,
uh,
pointed in any one direction other than what we're really doing right now.
So it is very much a day to day sort of existence.
Um,
which,
which is why it's sort of an incompatible existence with goals,
with longterm goals,
you know,
with,
with figures and numbers and stuff.
I also,
I don't want to be upset about expectations.
So another thing I don't have or any really any expectations.
Um,
I would hate to,
for example,
let's say,
let's say the company was,
we were expected to grow 22%.
Next year,
I'm making up numbers here,
right?
Uh,
and we grew 21 like that would be a reason it a lot of companies to be upset.
That is a ridiculous reason to be upset.
Everyone would be upset with that.
When you set off these numbers in these goalposts,
in these goals and these expectations and you don't hit them,
then you're just,
then you're upset and once you've actually either hit them or not hit them,
then you come up with another set and you just keep moving these,
these,
these moments of um,
possible joy but most likely disappointment and a lot of cases and I just don't
feel like setting those up for myself.
So I just ignore the whole thing.
Okay.
Uh,
I've,
I have all of these various bits and pieces that I've gathered through research
and I suspect that I'm just going to get hung up on a couple of things I really
want to explore and that's just going to be the way it goes.
Let's go into it.
All right.
There are many people listening to,
are familiar with base camp and the blog and so on.
And her saying,
I would love to have a company or a product is successful is base camp,
but I don't know how to go from where I am,
which is goal oriented,
having Kpis,
etc. To
perhaps the other end of the spectrum,
which is closer to Jason.
So I suppose embedded into that is the question of should they even want to
emulate that?
Uh,
but,
but secondly,
if someone said yes,
I've decided I want to move more in that direction,
what might be a step they could take or steps they could take to inch them a
little bit closer to,
uh,
where you are in a little further away from,
Oh my God,
I wanted to at 22 we,
we hit 21 we're a failure,
right?
Well first off,
I do want to make it really clear that this is simply what works for me in our
organization.
So I am not suggesting this is the only way,
the best way,
whatever this,
this works for us.
So,
if,
if what works for you works for you and you're very goal oriented and KPI driven
and you think,
you know,
you need to,
to the things you measure the thing or whatever it is,
figure how that saying goes.
Um,
what you,
what you measure is what you move or whatever.
I don't know what gets measured gets managed.
That's the one,
right?
So,
so if you're,
if you're like that and you think that are great for you and things are working
well for you,
please do not even consider changing.
Like keep doing that.
I think though,
if you're doing all of those things and you feel a sense of sort of the lack of
fulfillment or you're maybe consistently disappointed or you're reaching for
things that you can't seem to grab,
um,
I would suggest,
you know,
trying a little bit,
trying some of the things I'm suggesting,
which is pull back your expectations a bit.
Um,
just sort of tried to set out to do the best you can versus,
uh,
tried to measure up with a number that you've made up.
And that's the other thing that I think is important here is that any projection
that you set out to to hit is a guests like your,
your,
you,
you personally are making or someone at your organization,
whatever it is,
making a guess and they're picking a number and they're saying,
this is where we think we should be because this is sort of what we did last
year.
And because of that,
we want to do a little bit better this year,
but all the stuff is still just manmade.
None of these things are,
are,
are inherent in existence.
They're all man made things.
These numbers,
these goals is figure.
So if you can begin to strip that back and sort of recognize that that's the
case and say like,
what if I tried to function without setting any of these,
but I just did the best work I can anyway because isn't that what I should be
doing anyway,
no matter what.
So my suggestion would be,
as with anything,
um,
I'm not a big fan of,
of trying to massively change anything at once.
So I think,
um,
my suggestion would be like whatever the next project you have that,
that you're working on,
um,
if you would normally set out some goalposts are set out some,
some figures to hit or whatever,
or measure this,
just try not measuring one of those things.
Just pick one little tiny thing that you can throw away and not worry about and
see what happens.
And you'll probably find that,
that,
that the sky isn't falling into businesses and car isn't crashing and people
aren't running aimlessly around.
Not wondering what are wondering what to do.
That actually,
in fact,
um,
people will,
if you,
if you explain why you're doing it because you want to make this better because
simply you want to make it better and you think it could be better or whatever.
And you lay that out,
that people will be motivated enough by that,
that,
that the numbers and the figures don't necessarily,
they're not the things that are pulling you forward.
What's pulling you forward hopefully is your intrinsic motivation in your,
and your desire to do a better job at what you're doing.
And,
and the sort of appreciation of the craft and the respect of the work that
you're doing and who you're doing it for and that that's kind of enough and that
everything else is sort of a side effect of that.
Um,
so anyway,
I'd say pick one little thing,
throw it away,
don't worry about it and see what happens.
You'll probably find out that everything's just okay and then maybe you'll have
the courage to try it with another little thing that you are measuring that you
don't really care so much about.
And I know I'm well aware that this flies in the face of a lot of people's
worldview and maybe even years.
I know you're big into measuring things,
especially health wise and whatnot.
So again,
I think it comes down to also most importantly knowing who you are and what
matters to you and not trying to be like somebody else.
There's a lot of people trying to be like other people and uh,
I don't want anyone to try and be like
me.
You should be like yourself and if there's 5% of what I'm saying makes sense to
you,
then maybe you can pull that in and make that part of you too.
But I don't think you should be out there trying to be someone else cause that's
a bit of an artificial,
a situation you made it.
You've,
you've mentioned directly and alluded to perhaps a few things I'd like to
underscore just for folks listening.
The first is that you,
when you,
when one reads a quote or here's a quote,
like what gets measured,
gets managed,
uh,
it can often be taken to me and that you should manage everything in.
Therefore,
you should measure everything.
And that there is only upside in measuring,
but that's simply not the case.
Uh,
and for instance,
whether it's the,
I remember Andy Grove,
I believe it was an intimate talking about how for every metric that you track
and hold people accountable for,
you have to include,
identify and then also assess the perverse incentive you've created,
uh,
by imposing that metric.
So if,
if,
if people respond to incentives and you create a metric,
humans being humans,
they will look for easier and easier ways to say goose that number up or chop
that number down and you have to be aware of what that does to their behavior
and so on within the company.
But secondly,
measurement there,
there are things worth measuring and then there are things not worth measuring
that can become vanity metrics that people use just to feel productive,
uh,
instead of being productive.
And just to point to one thing that you,
you mentioned,
which I think a lot of people uh,
would assume of me that that is,
I,
uh,
I physically track a lot of things all the time and not say you assume that,
but,
uh,
there is a point to my tracking which is identifying what works for say my
physiology,
what harms me based on my genotype or whatever it might be.
And then I,
and then I just stop the vast majority of measurement and do it very
intermittently.
Right.
The,
uh,
the,
the follow up to that,
but I'd love to ask for people,
since you mentioned you don't read much,
if any trade publications or news,
what do you read?
What are you reading?
And maybe that's another opportunity for people to pare back on a,
I'm not going to say thoughtless,
it's too judgmental,
but a habit that perhaps consumes a lot of time without adding much value.
Uh,
so what do you,
what do you are,
if not that kind of stuff,
what type of stuff do you read and what are you,
what have you been reading recently or what are you reading?
Yeah,
I'll,
let me get to that in one second.
But I had a thought about the previous question or
sort of the genesis of this for me is,
um,
I used to do a lot of jogging.
I still do a little bit,
but,
um,
I kind of had some knee surgery while ago and so I've sort of not doing it as
much,
but I remember I'm trying to hit certain times,
like I want to,
um,
you know,
run a six and a half minute mile or whatever it was at the time.
And you know,
I'd go out and I'd run a six minute mile and 42 seconds.
And I remember being disappointed by that and,
and
I remember feeling like White,
why should I be disappointed in that?
I'm not running a race,
I'm not competing against anybody,
I'm sort of competing as myself,
but I set that up for myself.
That's not something I had to do.
Like I created that moment to be upset.
What if I just went out and ran because I enjoy running and just kind of run the
best I can every time I run and,
and just do that.
And I found that I started doing that and I enjoyed it more and didn't mean I
didn't run faster or slower.
I didn't even necessarily know and it didn't really matter.
I could feel whether or not,
like it was a good run,
like that was a good run.
I had a good run today was sort of a much better way to figure out my sort of
satisfaction then to measure it and say it was a six minute and 42 minute run
versus a six minute 38 second run.
Uh,
and I think that that's kind of where it sort of came into play for me in
business too.
So I think I pulled it from that and I wanted to share that because I just
remembered that,
that that was sort of a moment.
And I don't remember how old I was when I did that was probably actually in high
school or early in college or something where I started to think that way.
And that's maybe where that,
where that came from too.
But anyway,
I wanted to get that in there.
Um,
uh,
reading,
what am I read?
Well,
um,
you know,
I started reading the paper more,
uh,
which is like the newspaper and not,
not,
not online news sources,
but actually the newspaper.
And this happened because I was at a hotel,
there's a few years ago,
it was at a hotel and you know,
you go to a hotel and they ask you check in,
they say,
you know,
Joe,
would you like a newspaper?
And I used to always go,
no newspaper,
who,
who reads newspapers anymore.
Um,
you know,
cause I get all my news on the Internet,
which is instant all the time.
And the thing is most of that is not actually news,
it's entertainment.
Um,
I think the news like once a day is actually a perfectly good pace for the news.
So if you get the news in the morning,
uh,
you're basically getting all of yesterday's stuff that happened in the world.
That was,
it's someone,
you know,
some editors decided was important and uh,
and,
and they just said,
they put that in the news,
they print it,
and the next morning you get it.
Um,
and then if you wait another full day to get the news again,
pretty good chance,
uh,
that you didn't miss anything actually by paying attention to things all the
time.
Very few things happen during the middle of the day that you really absolutely
need to know that you can't wait for the next morning to know.
And so I've realized that the newspaper is actually a better way to get the news
because it's better,
the pace is better.
Um,
it,
it prevents you from searching and seeking out news that you don't need to know
about necessarily.
It prevents you from,
um,
playing the sport.
I call it the sport of information,
like trying to,
to,
to know more than everybody else and be like,
be faster to the latest story than everybody else did it,
this turning into a sport and in fact the news is presented.
If you watch any,
any news channel,
now it's presented as a sport.
I mean,
you've got these Chiron's going across the bottom,
these graphics scrolling across,
you've got talking heads that are sort of debating it.
You,
you turn on ESPN or you can turn on CNN and,
and if you hit the logos,
you wouldn't,
couldn't tell the difference really.
And,
um,
so,
so news coverage has turned into sports coverage and vice versa.
And I just would rather say like once a day is enough,
uh,
of,
of a general,
um,
interval for me to be relatively well informed about what's really going on in
the world.
Also at the resolution that matters.
I think the other problem I'm having,
and by the way,
I look at Twitter and I click on links here and there and I read some stuff that
I like,
but,
but for the most part,
um,
I'm not trying to find out what happened in hour ago.
And that to me is actually the real advantage to something like the newspaper
where you simply cannot find out what happened an hour ago because what happened
an hour ago in most cases,
doesn't matter.
Now you could say what if there's a national disaster or a major tragedy your
school shooting in your kids at the school?
Like there's all sorts of moments of course,
where realtime truly does matter,
but for the most part it doesn't matter at all.
And in fact it's worse because you become a it,
there's the fear of missing out.
Like I,
I think of it as Joe Mo,
like the joy of it
missing out this out
on those things.
Is that,
what did you come up with that?
Yeah,
I mean that's in our new book,
which is like,
it just,
it's great.
I don't need to know all this stuff all the time and,
and yeah,
again,
like look,
if there's a,
if there's,
I'm in La Right now,
if there's a mud slide like coming to my house,
like I should know about that.
Right.
Obviously.
But that's something that might happen every,
you know,
hopefully never in maybe once a decade.
And to say that I need to be informed a realtime about anything that could
possibly happen anytime,
because that one thing might happen once,
that's just a recipe for anxiety and I've tried to avoid that at all.
It all
costs.
Definitely.
Yeah.
No,
I know you are a fan.
To give one example of a book titled Seeking Wisdom From Darwin to Mongolia by
Peter Bevel.
And uh,
could you describe,
we're just explain why you like that book,
which is also one that I love.
It was actually sent to me by Derek Sivers of all people.
Folks can look him up.
Tim.
Dot.
Blog forward slash Sivers if you want to learn more about him,
but seeking wisdom from Darwin to monger by Peter Devlin.
Great Book.
Can you explain why you liked that book and any books that,
uh,
that you're also fond of?
Yeah,
so it's been a while since I've read that.
So book review would,
would be really embarrassing,
but I'll tell you is this,
um,
I love Charlie Munger and Warren Buffet is what I love about those two guys.
And of course this book is not written by them,
but it's sort of the,
the,
the spirit of it,
which has this very clear direct,
no bullshit,
a way of writing this very sort of simple folksiness that you know,
what life really necessarily,
I mean,
I know this is a broad generalization,
but in most cases it's not that complicated.
We tend to make things very complicated and we tend to make things very hard on
ourselves.
But really there's some basic fundamentals of many things that if you kind of
understand those,
you're in pretty good shape and you don't need to go much further than that.
And I love that kind of wisdom.
I love old people in general.
So Warren Buffet and Charlie monger,
I think mongers in his nineties now and buffets in his eighties but they've
always had this kind of wisdom,
which is this old school almost farmer's Almanac style wisdom.
And I've always been attracted to that because I think complexity is also become
a sport where it's like the more complicated something is,
the better you know,
the better you think you are at.
It is like if you make it more complicated,
you're better at it or something.
And I just think it's kind of the opposite.
So I love those guys in that book to me,
sort of highlighted a lot of that kind of thinking.
Um,
and so anything that that mongers written,
I love reading like Warren Buffett's letter to shareholders,
which I think is a,
is a must read for anybody.
100% agree.
It's,
yeah,
forget even just business people.
Just if you want to read clear writing,
uh,
if you want to understand what it's like to communicate something at a high
level,
you've got to read what he writes.
So that's the kind of stuff I love the tree.
I love to read.
I like Bayzos his shareholder letters as well for similar reasons.
That's the kind of stuff I'm really interested in.
It.
I don't read fiction at all.
Uh,
and maybe I'm missing out there,
but I,
I just,
my argument is always that I feel like the,
the world is so interesting on its own,
uh,
that there's more than enough.
I can read about real stuff.
I know some people are going to just hate me for this and I,
and I always get hate on it.
Um,
but I,
I just would rather read biographies or I'd rather read about nature.
I'd rather read about that stuff cause this,
the world is fascinating as it is.
So those are the kinds of things I'm into these days.
Uh,
and I,
you know,
I've been reading,
I know you're in deep into this now.
I've been reading a lot about stoicism and been getting into that so that the,
um,
uh,
the,
um,
is it the art of Joe Ancient Art of joy or someone said,
uh,
yeah,
the art of Joy by William says on the wing or other,
I'm blanking.
I'll put it in the show notes for everybody,
which is a compilation of both,
I suppose,
excerpts and samples,
but also interpretations and applications of Stoic Philosophy.
Love.
I want to say been William Irving.
Maybe that's it.
That's it.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
I think that's it.
So I read that recently or last year.
I really loved that.
I've been getting into a bit of that.
Um,
I don't know.
That's the kind of stuff I'm into these days.
Why is that?
Um,
stoicism or just stoicism.
Yeah.
Um,
it just resonates with me.
A few,
a few basic things.
By the way,
I don't need to go that deep into it.
Again,
it's not like I need to go super deep into the,
you know,
the whole,
the whole world of it.
But basically things like,
you know,
you,
you pretty much only have control over your reactions to things.
And I think that that is,
that in itself is enough.
I could stop there.
Uh,
I,
I go further,
but I could stop there and say that is extremely poignant.
Especially today.
I see people,
you know,
getting so wound up,
uh,
about what other people say and what are other people do.
And uh,
you know,
when you,
when you begin to see that what they're actually being wound up about is their
own reaction to that thing,
not the thing itself,
the thing itself,
you know?
Yeah,
maybe it's terrible,
maybe it's great,
whatever it is,
but it's how you sort of respond to it and how you allow it to,
to affect you.
That's deep and really important.
And I think one of the best lessons I've learned in the past few years,
so there's that.
Also just negative visualization I think is a really wonderful tool and they're
paying a lot of attention to that and my life.
Can you just for people who aren't familiar with that,
would you mind describing that just in brief what that is?
Negative visualization.
Yeah.
As far as I understand it,
at least it's basically figuring out what the worst case scenario might be in
any given situation.
And coming to terms with that and sort of realizing that probably in many cases
it won't be as bad as you think it could be.
So get,
get used to the worst thing,
and David and I talk about this occasionally,
right?
So DHH and I talk about this in the business,
like what if we made some grave,
grave,
horrible error.
So the business has been in business for 18 years and what if like,
or what if the competition destroys us or whatever.
Like what if we actually go out of business in two years?
Like what if that actually happens?
We don't want that to happen.
What if it did?
Like what's the worst thing that would happen?
Well,
it would be terrible because a lot of people would lose their jobs and that
would suck.
But we think a lot of people work for us would have no problem finding other
jobs.
So that would maybe be so bad.
Um,
I would have no income and Dave would have no income.
That would suck.
But we've done pretty well for ourselves.
So we can live,
we can live fine without that.
Um,
we couldn't do what we love doing every day.
Well that would kind of suck,
but maybe we could still do it,
just not in that capacity.
And you know what a 20 year run isn't so bad.
Like if we only made it 20 years in business,
that wouldn't be so bad either.
So just thinking about like what would be the worst thing that could possibly
happen and then,
you know,
recognizing that probably will not happen.
It just helps you,
I think,
calm down about that.
Um,
and it sort of avoid this constant set of worries in some ways.
You sort of get all the worrying out at once and then you go about your day and
go,
well,
if that happens,
then it happens.
At least I know what that's gonna feel like or what I think that might feel
like.
It's not that it would eliminate all of the feelings and there certainly would
be other negative feelings I may have missed.
But for the most part I've thought it through and I feel like I can probably
cope with it now if that actually happens versus having something surprise you,
um,
in the moment and having it be real,
that can be really traumatic and really difficult to handle.
So that's my general understanding of that at least.
That's a great description.
Definitely.
I think it's a great description.
And just by analogy,
I was just thinking this,
uh,
some sitting in this room where I do a lot of recording and I did an episode
like a former MMA fighter,
but also,
uh,
special forces sniper named Tim Kennedy.
And uh,
he's a beast of a fighter and a fascinating guy.
But he was saying,
oh,
in my bag right now I have x,
y,
and z firearm.
I have enough first aid that I could patch you in the videographer together.
If one of you had an arm chopped off,
I'm looking at how I could block the doorway in case of a,
B,
and c and he's,
he knows exactly how to assess the situation in specifics.
And the reason that I bring that up is as you were describing this negative
visualization,
I was thinking to myself,
it's something akin metaphorically speaking,
to taking a fear.
Let's just say you have a semi nebulous fear of something going wrong.
And let's say that fear is then embodied by a person and that person says,
I'm going to destroy you.
And then you run away and all day or all week you're thinking,
oh my God,
that person's going to destroy me.
How are they going to destroy me?
And there's this ambiguity that's really stress producing.
But if you were to sit down with that person and say,
okay,
I know you're going to just try me,
but I want to know exactly how you're going to destroy me.
I was like,
well,
first I'm going to ambush you at the corner of second and Colorado and uh,
I'm going to try to hit you with this type of bat.
And you're like,
okay,
now I like know where I know what they're going to do.
I have,
I can start planning a response,
right?
Or they say,
you know,
I'm going to beat you to death with a nerf baseball bat.
And you're like,
that's actually not going to beat me to death at all.
And you start to realize how recoverable a lot of this is.
Uh,
almost all of these fears are either completely unfounded or completely
recoverable or preventable.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's really
arguably the most valuable thing I've learned from any type of reading of
philosophy is this negative visualization,
which I tend to do in written form,
uh,
a lot,
in an exercise that I call fear setting,
which people can Google and find for free everywhere.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I'll stop my,
my,
my soapbox speech at this point about the fear setting and negative
distalization but it's extremely powerful and I think this is particularly true,
at least in my experience,
if you come from a family as I did of warriors,
people who spent a lot of time focused on the future with a high of anxiety and
whether that is,
uh,
in eight to my code,
to my DNA or simply an adopted set of behaviors and beliefs and thought
patterns,
I don't know,
maybe it's a combination,
but it's really been hugely,
hugely helpful.
Yeah.
You know,
I feel like that's similar.
Uh,
I,
I feel like I worried a lot and I still do.
I still battle with this and I do kind of feel like it is a battle actually in a
sense.
Um,
with worrying,
um,
[inaudible] I don't,
I stopped worrying about myself,
but I,
I have a three and a half year old now,
so I worry,
I worry about him and I find myself,
uh,
realizing that like kids are actually really quite resilient and I shouldn't be
worrying so much that that things are going to be just fine.
And it's actually a really good practice for me too,
to use negative visual,
negative visualization.
Um,
when I'm worrying about things like,
oh,
he's going to go go to school and get sick and then he's gonna have the flu and
then I'm going to get the flu and if I get the flu then I can't do this.
And their whole house,
my wife's gonna get the flu and she's pregnant.
And then like you go through all this stuff and it's like,
yeah,
that could happen.
And you know,
I can't,
you can't stop it.
I can't prevent kids go to school and they get sick and you might get sick and
like,
okay,
but if you think about how bad it can be,
you start to really ruminate on it versus like,
yeah that could happen.
And if that happens it happens.
You just deal with it and live with it and,
and,
but I remember before I got into this negative visualization,
I would actually worry a lot.
And what's cool about negative visualization I think is that it clears the worry
out of the room in a sense.
Like you give it a worry,
like you worry about it for a while and then it's,
and it's over.
The worrying is over.
And I think that's the key insight for me in it,
which is it gives me a moment to say,
yeah,
okay,
I'm going to worry about this and I need to worry about it as bad as it could
possibly be and think about how exactly horrible it could be and then I can then
I'm done with that.
And that's the difference compared to consistent low grade,
always on worry where you'd never have that moment where you can really confront
it until it happens,
when it usually doesn't.
Definitely.
And I looked,
I looked up the,
the title of the book,
The author is William B Irvine,
Irvine,
California.
And the title is a joy.
Wow.
I can't even read it correctly.
All right,
here we go.
They'd guide to the good life subtitle,
the ancient art of stoic joy.
And that's the one and it is a fantastic introduction to stoicism and by itself,
if you never read another book on the subject.
Extremely,
extremely helpful.
Yeah.
You mentioned,
you mentioned your,
uh,
your son,
right?
You have a son.
And I'm curious if we,
if we turn back the clock,
do you remember the first time you got in trouble or any memorable early memory
of getting into trouble?
Oh my God,
I got into so much trouble when I was younger.
Um,
the first time though,
um,
I remember the first time I cried so hard that I almost couldn't breathe.
You know,
that crying,
hyperventilating.
I remember why it happened,
but I'm sure I did something really bad.
Uh,
and,
and I think my,
my,
uh,
my parents like reminded me how bad it was.
There's something and I got really scared,
I think,
I don't remember how old I was,
but I remember that moment.
Um,
I,
but I,
I've gotten a lot of trouble when I was younger.
Probably should have gotten in more trouble.
I probably got away with too many things as well.
Um,
but,
uh,
I got,
I got into a lot of trouble with my parents who have to take me up at the police
station when I was younger,
when I was younger.
Like I'm talking like 15,
that's like that kind of thing.
Or 14 junior,
actually junior high was bad.
Like what does that 13,
14 something that similar kind of area?
Yeah,
I was,
I was really bad.
I kind of got in with a,
with a bad crowd and,
and,
and started doing some bad stuff.
Um,
although it wasn't so bad.
What type of,
what,
what were the offenses?
Let's get specific.
Okay.
So it's actually entrepreneurial stuff
side by side.
Hustle right before it was called that.
Oh,
continue.
Sorry,
I'm just imagining the expression you just made like the winds as I,
as I said,
well
go ahead.
I was,
um,
I don't know when the entrepreneurial bug bit me,
but it didn't even really,
and um,
I loved,
um,
knives and like throwing stars and like switch blades,
although I couldn't get those cause it was a real legal,
um,
I just love that kind of stuff.
How I,
how old are you?
So you don't mind me asking?
Um,
I'd probably today 43.
Okay.
So yeah,
we,
so we're of the same vintage,
so I had too much caffeine,
so I'm interrupting you.
But the uh,
we grew up when like Ninjas and breakdancing were as cool as it could,
as cool as you could possibly be.
And there was a catalog called Asian world of martial arts.
I don't remember this.
Awma yeah.
Anyway,
just to put some context.
So at that time people like you and me,
it was not infrequent that young guys,
definitely,
mostly young guys would fantasize about throwing stars and climbing clause and
grappling hooks.
So just on that,
just to set on stage,
please continue.
So
how,
I don't remember how this happened somehow.
Maybe it was my dad who got on this mailing list or I got on this,
like we were starting to get these catalogs at home and one of them was that
one,
another one is called sportsman's guide.
Um,
there's a few other ones where it's kind of like army surplus sees stuff and I
don't really remember exactly how it all happened,
but I started looking through the pages and there were these cool knives and
throwing stars and like some ballistic nights,
like knives,
you can actually shoot with a spring,
like crazy shit.
It's crazy stuff.
And I just got into it and like tear gas and let's kind of weird shit.
So,
so as this,
I mean,
at 13 year old boy,
for me it was just the coolest thing in the world,
right?
I don't know why,
but I was so into it and for sure I started to take these catalogs and make
xerox copies of these pages and then cut them out and then reassemble my own
catalog.
Um,
and I would like re I would,
I would kind of scratch out the prices and,
and like put new prices on them and then make catalogs,
which I would then distribute to my friends,
my friends.
Then I would buy these knives and stuff for me.
Um,
I would then,
so I'd take these orders and I would make an order form and everything and I
would take these things,
and this is back in like 85.
I remember I got my first Mac in [inaudible] 85 and so I was like using my Mac
to like print stuff out and my image writer or whatever I had at the time.
And I'd make these catalogs and these order forms and print the stuff out and
distributed to some friends and they would like make orders.
I get the,
I get the cash in them.
They,
everyone had like part time jobs so they give me some cash.
I'd get the cash,
I would place an order through these catalogs for this stuff.
I'd order it cod because,
which I don't know if they have that anymore called cash on delivery.
I don't think they have that anymore,
but I didn't have a credit card.
For those of you who are much younger and don't remember or don't know what this
was,
ups could actually come to your tier house,
bring a package and you would pay the ups driver,
the ups driver,
then take that money and put an envelope and then send it back to the company.
That's how you'd actually buy things sometimes.
So anyway,
I get cash,
I'd order stuff,
cod,
I'd fake that I was sick that day and stay home from school.
I knew when it was gonna be delivered,
the ups driver would come,
I would give him the cash,
uh,
and I get these things and I distribute them to my friends and I would make
profit.
Um,
and then I did that with like cigarettes and chewing tobacco and all sorts of
stuff.
And so I kinda like that.
Then I had a bit of a reputation as a Pyro,
cause I love fireworks and fire and stuff.
So I'd like,
Hey.
Anyway,
I got,
I got into a lot of trouble eventually as you can imagine,
selling contraband to a 15 year old boys in the suburbs of Chicago.
Um,
and then like,
you know,
I kinda got in with the wrong crowd and then like all sorts of weird things
happen at some point.
But anyway,
um,
eventually got that out of my system.
But I,
that's how I started getting into being an entrepreneur is,
is that,
and I love the idea of carving up other people's catalogs and making my own.
And then I got a resellers license somehow and got into electronics and started
being able to buy things at like dealer costs from these big distributors.
And then like for example,
radar detectors,
so people could,
my friends could speed that,
you know,
16 so like,
let's go speed,
let's go get it and returned,
tucked her in her car.
So I buy writer or to,
or is it like costs doubled the price on and my friends cause they couldn't get
them.
And telephone like cordless phones,
you know,
back then like,
and then computer hard drives in the early days.
And then computers and that's Kinda how I got into all this stuff.
But it was,
it was,
um,
it's funny cause like the way I think about business today,
even the business I'm in today,
base camp,
I just see it as a continuation of when I was 13 selling knives,
honestly,
like it's all one business where I'm buying or making the thing that I want and
then finding other people who want the same thing.
It's the same business as it ever was when I was at 13 and is today,
um,
I'm not selling illegal stuff now,
but then that same spirit and uh,
anyway,
so I got in trouble.
I don't remember what,
you know,
I got in trouble probably before that too,
but my parents let me get away with a lot as an only child.
So I think they'd let me get,
get away with extra,
an extra amount of stuff.
Um,
but,
uh,
those early days I think paved the way for me to really learn,
how to,
you know,
how to sell things,
how to market things,
how to promote things,
how to package things,
how to mark things up,
and how to also charge for things,
which is in a strange way,
the thing that's so deficient about our industry today or the tech industry,
which is like a lot of people don't,
they don't,
a lot of companies don't charge for it.
They give stuff away for free and then they have to live with all of these
other,
um,
uh,
the negatives of that,
which we're even seeing play out in the news now.
Um,
so anyway,
I learned a lot of lessons from doing the wrong thing.
Let's say
you mentioned a bunch of weird things happened.
We're not,
we don't necessarily have to go into that,
although I'm certainly happy to go into one of them.
Let's do it.
And then you're like,
I got it out of my system.
I'm like,
well,
for a lot of people,
they never quite get it out of their system.
So there had to be,
I would imagine catalyzing event or events or something that encouraged you to
get her once.
So let's,
let's go into one.
There wasn't,
there weren't.
So first of all,
um,
I had this friend,
I won't mention his name,
but he was a bad influence on me.
Um,
my parents had spotted him,
immediately said,
this kid's no good.
We don't want to,
we don't want you to be with this kid.
But anyway,
um,
I still was cause he was cool and I wanted to be cool.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
one day during lunch,
um,
we put a,
uh,
like a tic tac,
like a mint.
It wasn't a tic TAC,
but as some sort of mint in this other kid's milk.
Okay.
At school.
And,
um,
after he drank his milk,
we told them,
this is again,
I'm so ashamed of this whole thing.
But anyway,
um,
we told them that we poisoned him.
Right,
right.
Bad.
It's bad.
And how old are you?
You're 15,
15 or something like pork.
This is kind of,
I mean,
I hate to say it,
not to excuse it,
but sort of par for the course.
15 year old boy behavior
shitty.
But I'm just being honest.
So we did that obviously didn't poison anybody,
but like we told them we did.
Okay.
And um,
and it's funny because we,
it wasn't a bullying thing is actually a friend of ours.
So it wasn't like,
it wasn't like we were picking on anybody.
He's like a friend of ours and,
and we did this anyway in math class later that day he passes out because he was
probably anxious and thought we poisoned him.
So he has to get his stomach pumped because he thought he told,
he told them,
it's like he told the teachers then they'd like the police got involved and he'd
been poisoned and I had to go down to the police station.
My parents had it like take me to the police station and all this shit.
And it was like,
it was,
it was a mint,
you know,
but it was,
it was,
we set this up in a way where he didn't think it was.
And so on.
Anyway,
that was some of the shit I got into.
And eventually I got into that and a couple of the things.
Um,
eventually my parents said,
hey,
look,
um,
enough,
uh,
if you get in trouble again,
we're sending you off to boarding school.
Um,
which means you're,
you're,
you're away from all your friends and your way from us and the whole thing.
And it was that statement alone that changed everything for me.
I don't know why either.
I didn't even know what boarding school was.
It probably sounded kind of cool.
Like I get to go away and sleep away.
Like there's something kind of almost cool about it in a sense,
like when you don't really know what it would be,
but they said it in such a stern way that it was so clear that this was not
where I want it to go and what I wanted to or I want it to be.
Right.
The tone made it clear.
It was not desirable for you.
Yes.
And that was the moment when I basically Aye.
Aye.
Went back to my old friends were awesome.
I never really left them,
but I kinda sorta did and,
and they were very cool about it and they kind of welcomed me back basically.
And I just stopped doing all that shit.
I just stopped it.
Um,
and it sounds like how,
how could I have just stopped it?
But it's probably because I wasn't really,
it was sort of this,
this stunt that I was pulling and not really what I wanted to do was just kind
of a fun thing when I realized that there were consequences and once I realized
are true consequences,
I,
uh,
I changed it and I think that was kind of the,
the thing for me is that,
um,
especially when I was younger,
I would sort of do things I remember like,
so I went to Hebrew school like after school and I hated it,
absolutely hated it because it was like two hours Tuesdays and Thursdays after
school.
I wasn't religious.
My parents weren't really either,
but they sort of,
it was just sort of something that everyone in the neighborhood did.
And I kind of did.
And it was out of respect for my grandparents who were more religious anyway.
So I went to this thing like two days a week after school and I would,
I remember,
I remember my dad telling me once it like,
um,
cause I was,
I was kind of bad there too.
I was actually extra bad there.
I would always like question the teacher's like,
well wait,
prove it.
Can you prove that God again,
is this like stuff like that.
I was just being an asshole,
you know,
and cause like I was just pushing them cause I knew you couldn't prove it and
was just being,
and so that was just like,
uh,
being difficult anyway.
Um,
I got in trouble and my dad would be surprising to hear.
Right.
And so my dad,
my dad's like,
you know,
he's like,
you shouldn't do this,
but I just want you to know,
like none of this goes on your record in other record that you always,
I don't know if you've ever threaten her.
Yeah,
exactly.
Pristine record as a kid.
So I had the,
the record and there is no record thing,
but I didn't know what at the time until my dad's like,
so my dad's like,
you know,
this isn't gonna go on your record and actually like made me do more bad shit.
Um,
and eventually I got kicked out of Hebrew school,
um,
for like doing some other stuff,
which I really don't go into gross insubordination.
Yeah.
Basically.
And they just had enough of me and they knew I had enough of them and the whole
thing and they let me like go through and do get my bar Mitzvah and they like,
let me do that,
but they're like,
just don't come to school anymore.
Okay.
Um,
so that was creative differences.
Yeah.
So anyway,
all those things,
like at some point I just,
I,
my parents kind of said boarding school or,
you know,
stop or this and I stopped and,
um,
you know,
back then I,
I,
you know,
as,
as high school kids,
do you drink a bit.
And I got that all on my system also.
Like all that stuff.
I kind of get out of my system.
And this comes from one of the reasons I didn't really like college cause in
college everyone was experimenting with stuff for the first time.
In a sense I feel like I'd already been through all that.
And so the social experience in college was,
was actually really boring for me and,
and almost felt childish actually because I felt like I'd been through it when I
was a child and now I see everyone else doing that.
And so I didn't really enjoy college at all for that reason.
Um,
and I just sort of kind of muddled through and got it done.
and then by that point I was already doing website design,
like freelance.
I had a software business that I had already started on the side selling
software that I've made to organize my own music collection and all this stuff I
started sort of doing.
And to me college was actually just getting in the way of me getting out there
and doing the things that I really wanted to do.
So you mentioned organizing your music collection and uh,
we,
we could dig into that.
I remember reading a story about it,
people could send you in $20 uh,
to get audio file right.
They'd be to upload to AOL.
And so I read the story of getting this,
you were getting this envelope from Germany or some other country,
the Air Mail envelope that I'm sure some people have seen with the red and blue
around the edges and uh,
Lo and behold,
right order form $20 bill,
like big deal.
It was that the first time that you were like,
Holy Shit,
like I could do this or I'm an entrepreneur or I'm successful.
Like,
do you remember,
uh,
of these many entrepreneurial experiments and ventures that you've been involved
with was,
was there a particular incident that stands out?
Like,
wow,
holy shit like this.
This is something that I could actually make a living doing?
I could do this.
Yeah.
The 20 well,
first of all,
I never thought about making a living really,
but I thought about what was different about the,
the the software getting 20 bucks in the mail for software that I made was that
I was the first time I realized,
actually let me step back.
I,
I've been selling stuff before.
We talked about that,
like sort of throwing stars to that Shit.
I had to do work for that.
Like I had to work,
I had to make a sale each time I had to get inventory.
Each time I would sell inventory to have to get more inventory.
I have to go out and convince my friends to buy more shit.
Right.
What was different about the software thing was that I could make this thing
once.
I could put it out there into the world and a lot of people could pay me for it
and I could in a sense make money while I was sleeping.
I didn't think about it necessarily that way.
I do like I can look back on it now and say that's what I felt.
I didn't feel it that way,
but what I did realize was that I could make something that I wanted.
Um,
I could put a lot of effort into it and put it out there and let it speak for
itself.
And if people liked it,
they'd be happy to pay for it and that people are happy to pay for things and
that like,
I don't have to go out and sell each one.
I could put it up and people could buy it from all over the world when they find
it on their own.
That was,
I think the distinctly different thing for me at that moment versus everything
else I'd done in the past was sort of one off sales,
including like,
you know,
eventually I was doing some logo design and website design,
which came a little bit later,
uh,
after,
well actually,
I'm not sure what the timeline was,
but even that you have to find a client every time and you a find someone new
every time and the whole thing,
um,
and,
and software was different.
And that's probably,
and that's what I do today cause I make software,
we put it out there and technically,
technically you're making money while you're sleeping because it's running and
people pay you on a monthly basis and,
uh,
you know,
you kind of make it once and put it out there versus,
although of course you're making it every day,
you're changing it and tweaking it,
but it's still the same spirit.
So that was the big change for me,
I think.
Um,
and then,
you know,
I,
I realized that,
um,
the,
the deeper realization though,
again,
is that like,
I don't,
I can make this for myself.
I can satisfy myself and that then the next step is to find other people like
you versus trying to dominate an industry.
And I think this is a fundamental thing that we have today at base camp,
which is I have no interest Dj.
Should I talk about it?
That we have no interest in dominating anyone or any thing.
We don't land.
I'm not out for land grab.
I don't know what our market share is.
I could care less.
It doesn't matter to me.
Uh,
none of this stuff.
I'm not looking to put any competitors out of business.
I'm not looking to,
to,
to be number one.
None of that stuff matters.
What matters is,
can I make something that I like?
Can we put it out there to support our costs and make more money than we spend?
And if that means we have 1% market share or 0.1% market share,
fine with me.
I don't care if it means we have 50% market share found me.
I don't care.
None of that matters.
What matters is can I,
what,
can I build something I like and can it be sustainable and connect,
fund our,
our continued development and endeavors.
And that's also what the music thing,
cause I made it for myself.
I was loaning out my cds and tapes to friends and never getting them back.
And I forgot who I loved them too.
And so I'm like,
well what maybe if I organize this I could like have an inventory of all the
stuff.
I have bootlegs and cds and the whole thing.
And whenever I loaned out to someone,
I'll just like note the date and who it was.
And then I have the,
I'll build a system that will send me a reminder about that 30 days later and I
can go,
hey,
hey bill,
remember that CD that I led you have?
I said I need this weekend.
Like I still don't have it.
And then I would get all my stuff back.
And so,
you know,
that's kind of what,
what I've been doing ever since.
It says building stuff that,
that works for me.
So I want to tell a story through your words about how the world welcomed you
with open arms and immediately started buying everything that you have to sell.
So I'd like to read a bit of text here.
Okay.
Uh,
and I'm pretty sure this is not a misquote since you a typed it out and sent it
to me sometime ago.
Here we go.
Way Back in the 90s when I was getting started as web designer,
I sent my work into an award site called high five.com at the time it was the
shit,
if you were awarded a high five words,
you were recognized.
Now I sent my stuff in and then we leave his name out just so I don't have
anybody chasing me around.
The Guy who ran it emailed me back.
I don't have the original email anymore,
but basically he told me I sucked.
I had no business being in the web design business and that I should never email
him again.
That rejection filled me with so much fire,
not anger,
not resentment,
not disappointment,
but fire,
fire to kick ass and prove his impression wrong.
I love the rejection.
It made me,
and that was in response to a question I asked you,
which was how has a failure or apparent failure set you up to leave success?
That was in my last book,
tribe of mentors and my question about this,
and you can certainly take this anywhere you want if you want to elaborate,
correct.
Do anything else,
but my question,
uh,
speaking personally as someone who has struggled with anger,
I mean I spent so much of my childhood being bullied really badly.
I was born premature,
really,
really small and with a lot of health issues up until about sixth grade that I
built up this anger that I used as fuel to then later compete and fight and do
all of these things so that I wouldn't be taken advantage of it again.
Oh,
effectively,
right.
I mean there was just a coping mechanism and now I've realized that anger is
very often not helpful and that it is the acid that damages the vessel,
not that which it is poured upon.
Right.
So the,
the,
the line,
I'll read it again.
That rejection filled me with so much fire,
not anger,
not resentment,
not disciplined,
but fire.
How in what was the self talk that made it fire and not anger or resentment,
if that makes any sense.
Or how do you,
how you transmute what could be a negative response into something that's
actually helpful in a case like this?
Yeah,
I remember that distinctly because um,
it was the first time I got enough courage up to sort of submit work to a d to a
award site thing and the rejection was so uh,
in your face,
like you suck,
basically don't do this.
Um,
that it,
because it was so,
it was almost a caricature of a row of a rejection.
Like they're actually going to be like,
you suck.
Don't do this.
Like no one would ever say that.
But he did
that.
It almost made me laugh and be like,
I'm just going to prove you wrong.
It was that kind of energy that was the fire.
Like I have always in those cases,
I've always responded to those sorts of moments as,
as,
as motivation to prove somebody wrong or to like prove myself.
Right.
Maybe,
uh,
and maybe that's sort of a bit of the flaw.
I still have to work out or one of those too,
but I just wanted to,
to say,
okay,
well fuck you.
I'm going to show you that I can do this.
And I don't even know.
I don't,
I shouldn't even care right now.
I realize that this is like my reaction to someone like,
Oh,
who cares about this guy?
Who cares what he thinks about my work?
Um,
it's also tied to the fact that like,
I just,
I know,
you know,
look,
um,
obviously I come from a position of privilege to say this whole thing,
but like,
I've just,
I don't let people offend me.
And I have been in situations where,
uh,
like for example,
I mentioned that I mentioned earlier,
I'm Jewish and I remember in college some people called me a Kike,
which is a fucking horrible slur.
And I,
I've,
I've had people,
like I've walked by a penny and they're like,
oh,
you should pick that up.
Like,
I,
I've had some of that shit.
Right.
Um,
and it's like,
it doesn't matter.
I don't care.
To me,
that kind of stuff.
Uh,
just,
there's never upset me cause it's cause it's like that's just a reflection on
the other person's ignorance or point of view.
I've never let that kind of stuff get to me.
And I think that,
is that something your parents instilled in you?
I mean,
that's not the norm.
That's not the most common reaction.
Yeah.
I don't know where it came from.
I don't know where that came from,
but I've just never,
I've never remembered ever feeling offended by anyone's sort of slight at me for
whatever reason.
And like,
look,
I,
I'm,
you know,
I'm five,
seven,
so I'm relatively short guy.
Like there's been those kinds of things that you have,
like there's all sorts of stuff that,
that,
that you get,
you know?
Um,
and I know a lot of people have a way fucking worse than I do.
So I,
I totally get all of that.
I'm just using like,
like all the only examples I have are my own right.
And so,
but I,
I bet I've been in those situations where I could see someone flipping over it
and be like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
That's the horrible thing to say and well,
how could you ever say it somebody?
And I've just never felt that way.
I'm like,
okay,
that's where you come from.
Fine,
that's fine.
Like,
I,
I don't really even have the energy or the care to try and set you right or
whatever.
It's not my job.
I don't really want to do it.
Um,
I,
it is what it is.
It kind of disrupted,
bounces off me in a sense.
Um,
but one thing,
one reaction I have had is his motivation.
That's the thing that I've always had.
When someone says,
I can't do something or,
or I'm not this enough or I'm not that enough,
it's motivation to prove,
prove that wrong.
Um,
and I don't know if it's the dark and dirty side of it is like,
is it actually revenge or is it motivation?
And I'm not sure that I necessarily know,
uh,
what that is.
Maybe I think it's motivation,
but maybe it's more revenge,
which is a pretty crappy,
uh,
emotion or whatever that would be called.
Um,
but,
um,
I never do it trying to hurt somebody.
So maybe it is motivation,
not revenge,
but I'm not totally sure to be honest.
Um,
but I don't know where it came from.
Uh,
but,
um,
I just never remember ever being angry about something that someone said about
me or how they've judged me or whatever.
I just never really cared.
Well to maybe provide a contrast to that.
It,
um,
it seems like you have an importance for the wasting time because it seems like
you have a strong dislike for wasting time.
And you've,
you've talked about this before,
written about it.
What rules for yourself,
commandments,
systems,
anything do you have in place to help minimize time wasting?
So something I,
I think I had mentioned,
I wrote this up in your book actually as a response is sort of,
um,
first of all,
getting better at saying no is the critical thing to begin with.
And being honest about the things you really want to do and things you really
don't want to do and not sort of just doing things because you feel obligated
because it will make someone else feel good and like you who knows how someone
else is actually going to feel.
It's sort of presumptuous to suggest that I should do something because it'll
make someone else happy.
Uh,
it's actually kind of hard to know what makes people happy and,
and uh,
so I,
I try not to,
I try not to go down that road because I think you can find yourself in a
difficult spot and you know,
it's,
it's really hard to do.
Um,
so I've just tried to get better at saying no and really recognizing the things
I like to do and I don't like to do,
I've kind of described my,
my life has a weird description of my life,
but partial description on my life is like,
I just tried to do everything I can to avoid hassles.
I don't like hassles.
And to me a hassle is like something I don't want to do in the future.
It's almost never something I have to do now.
It's something you have to do in the future.
And so something I've been getting better and better at is,
is,
is basically just being honest with people who ask me to do things far,
far in advance and say I can't make commitments that far in advance.
I know that you need a commitment that far in advance.
They're planning an event or you're doing,
I totally understand that.
But I,
I,
I find that,
um,
I tend to,
this is a strong word and it's not fair.
It's what other people are doing.
So it's gonna come off strange.
But I don't think of it in terms of that,
that what they're about to do isn't worth it.
But I tend to regret things that I say yes too far in advance because not
because of the thing itself,
but because it actually prevents me from having opportunities to,
to,
to explore other things in the moment when I get there,
then I might be more interested in doing so this comes back to the goal setting,
perhaps.
Maybe it's all the same thing,
which is that I don't know how I'm going to feel six months from now on Friday
night at four o'clock,
uh,
speaking,
you know,
where I'm scheduled to speak in an event.
Maybe I'd rather not be doing that six months from now.
The only way I'm going to know that is to basically wait until that moment and
decide whether or not I want to do that.
But of course I can't cancel on people if,
if I,
if I booked at events,
you know,
so I've just,
I've just found in my life that the things I put on my calendar,
because it's so easy to put something foreign advanced on your calendar because
it costs nothing in a sense.
Um,
it doesn't take any of your time now.
It doesn't take any time next week.
It's like,
you know,
four months from now.
Sure I'll do that.
And then it comes up on that and I'm like,
I wish I wouldn't have said yes to that.
Not because of the thing itself,
but because of the feeling of,
of being now obligated to do something they may not choose to want to have done
in that moment.
Had I had the choice then or now,
can you give us some sample language or just a basic kind of template that you
would use to polite.
Decline.
Yeah.
Politely declined something.
Somebody hits you up,
let's just say you actually know them.
They're like,
hey,
six months from now on such and such a date,
we're having this event,
ABC impressive speakers are coming,
would let that blah,
blah blah.
Right.
So then what is your response look like?
Well,
I mean sometimes it that will
say yes,
but most of the time I'll say,
I'll say,
you know,
thanks for writing.
I appreciate the invitation.
Um,
I can't book anything that far in advance right now.
I have a hard time filling my calendar six months ahead of time or something
like that.
I'll let me think about the language.
Basically.
I wouldn't say,
I would say,
uh,
um,
I,
I can't book anything that far in advance.
Um,
sometimes it's because I'll,
I'll be specific,
like my wife is pregnant and I can't like died that's too close.
So I can't do that.
But there's other times I'm just like,
I just can't book that far in advance.
Um,
if if there's an opening closer and you need someone like Lemmy know,
then,
um,
I'd be happy to do it or perhaps another time.
But six months from now is,
it's just too far off for me to book things is kind of what I'll say.
Um,
and you know,
uh,
I always try to,
first of all,
it's an honor to be invited to anything.
The fact that anyone wants to hear me talk is still surprises me.
Um,
and so I'm always,
I always appreciate it and I'm sure I always make sure to lead with that,
but then I just,
I,
I'm honest about it,
which is I can't put anything on my calendar that far in advance.
I can't book things that far in advance.
Um,
also another thing,
like for example,
um,
I've been asked a lot recently to speak internationally and,
and,
um,
and I'll just tell people which is true.
Like I just don't like to travel internationally for business.
Um,
if I want to go somewhere,
I'd like to go somewhere because I,
you know,
for personal reasons,
but I,
I don't like to travel internationally for business,
so I'll just say like,
I,
I'm just not traveling internationally for business right now.
It's not something I'm really doing.
So I appreciate the invitation.
Again,
if you ever have an event that you had states let me know that kind of stuff.
Um,
because I think if you make up stories,
it's just why,
why,
why not just be honest and clear about it and,
and you know,
people are very understanding actually.
They go,
I totally get that.
Um,
hey,
if we have an opening,
I'll let you know,
uh,
if not,
no big deal.
Maybe another time,
maybe there's some other thing we have coming up that's that sooner I said,
yeah,
of course.
Let me know if something sooner.
That'd be,
that'd be great.
So it kind of do it that way.
And by the way,
this,
um,
I was sort of inspired by,
and I don't know if this is true,
I read somewhere that Warren buffet kind of does this with meetings.
I don't know if,
again,
I don't know if this is true.
I read it.
Um,
which is that if you want to meet with him,
uh,
you basically have to write his assistant or whatever the day before.
So if you,
if you,
if you write,
I'm sure there's exceptions to this rule,
but for most cases if you want to meet with him,
you can't say,
hey,
I'd like to meet with,
you know,
I'm going to be an Omaha in March,
uh,
March 22nd.
Uh,
can I,
can I meet up with Mr Buffet or something?
And uh,
the answer would be when you get an on the 21st,
uh,
email me then and if he has any openings the next day,
then he'd be happy to meet with you.
And now of course,
he's Warren Buffet people and I've written about this,
be like,
Oh,
he's Warren Buffet.
Like the thing is,
is that yeah,
he is Warren Buffet,
but you or you and your time is yours,
just like his is his and his attention is his and yours is yours.
And who cares how wealthy he is.
What does it have to do with any of this?
Who cares what position he's in.
I understand that.
Like,
yeah,
he,
he is in a position where he can maybe say no more frequently than others,
but so can a lot of people,
I don't think people give themselves enough credit and give no enough credit and
defend their own attention and time as they,
as much as they should.
Um,
people will,
will protect money,
they'll protect all sorts of things,
but they won't protect their,
their attention and their time.
And,
and,
uh,
I think more people should get better at that.
So I've been practicing getting better at that and I was sort of inspired in
part by,
by hearing about if it's true or not,
I don't know.
But hearing about how buffet does that and how people respond to the
boundaries that you set,
particularly if you do so tactfully tells you quite a lot about the,
uh,
the,
the nature of your true relationship.
That's true too with these people.
I remember one time I was going through a very difficult period and was trying
to set up a number of different rules to simplify and clear my calendar and it
also just took me a long time to get back to people,
even people I carried quite a lot about.
But the people who are really close to me know that that is the case.
Who knows,
I could be lost in the Amazon jungle for three weeks.
Like they don't get too upset about things.
And uh,
at one point I got a,
got an angry text from this,
uh,
more of an acquaintance,
very powerful guy.
And he said he was like,
Tim,
Dude,
what the hell?
Like you're harder to get ahold of than the president.
I just talked to him last week or something like that.
And then we hopped on the phone and he was really upset.
And I said,
well,
the president has a bigger team than I do.
And number one,
and number two,
like,
I hate to say it,
but you're being really aggressive right now.
Like of all the things on my list of priorities,
including my family and this,
and I mentioned a few things that were pretty heavy,
like you're kind of number 17 right now.
And that doesn't mean that you're unimportant to me,
but it means that you just have to wait until I'm done with the first 16.
So like if,
if you can't do that,
I get it,
I suppose,
but it's not gonna change.
And,
uh,
it's a,
it's definitely a learned skill.
Uh,
it means I've absolutely,
and you've maybe had this experience,
but when my first book came out,
I was so absolutely astonished that anyone would pay me anything to talk about
anything that I said yes to everything that came in.
And then six months later I was like,
oh my God,
I feel like I'm in death of a salesman.
This is,
yeah,
this is awful.
And,
um,
over time they become better at setting parameters.
You've mentioned,
uh,
since we're talking about Warren Buffet,
clear thinking and clear writing,
which you seem to value very highly and in doing a little bit of homework for
this conversation,
uh,
I've read and you can tell me if this is true or still the case,
but how one of your top hiring criteria is whether the person is a great writer,
uh,
whether the person can communicate well in written form is I'd love for you to
say whether that is still the case or not and why that is the case.
Yeah,
it's definitely the case.
It's sort of been the case for forever for us.
Um,
it's the case because first of all,
most communication is written these days.
Uh,
and first of all,
let me step back.
Like we're remote company,
so especially most of the communication is written.
Uh,
if you're going to have,
if you're a local company and you're having meetings all the time,
sometimes verbals enough,
but for most,
in most cases,
people are writing more and more and more than they ever have before.
Um,
and one of the most costly and inefficient things is having to repeat yourself,
uh,
or answer questions about something that should have been clear in the first
place.
Eh,
it's,
it's re really quickly if you can't communicate clearly,
um,
you're communicating probably three or four times more frequently than you need
to.
Um,
and that can be really inefficient and really frustrating,
extremely frustrating.
So we've always looked at writing as clear writing as,
as a,
as a prerequisite for every position we have at the company because everybody's
supposed to communicate with themselves,
with the rest of the company and with their team.
And most of it's done done via the written word.
And we also,
for example,
the first,
by the way,
the first sort of gatekeeper of it is,
is the,
is the cover letter.
So when people apply for a,
if they don't,
if they just like send a resume or whatever,
they're out instantly.
That's not even something we look at.
Um,
I always read or I always want to see a cover letter of some sort.
It can,
it can just be an email of course with a,
with an attachment of the resume or whatever.
But,
um,
I want to see how you,
how you open the conversation,
you know,
how do you describe yourself,
uh,
why,
why are you applying for this job and not just any job.
And you can tell very quickly if someone's going to,
if someone can explain themselves,
if someone can advocate for themselves and advocate for their ideas and their
position and who they are and why they should work here.
Um,
if,
if there,
if they're clear minded,
if they're friendly,
like all that stuff come through and writing.
I think if you pay enough attention to the words,
you can see a lot of that.
Um,
and uh,
um,
also for example,
when I hired designers,
I look at their design,
but I look at their writing almost a little bit more.
Um,
whenever we hire a designer,
when we get down to the last five candidates that we are really think could be
finalists,
we hire them to do a project for us,
um,
1500 bucks for a week.
And they do a project for us so we can kind of see their actual work.
But even more importantly is we ask them to write up why they did what they did.
Um,
because there's a lot of great designers out there,
but people have to advocate for themselves.
And so I want to see why they do what they did.
I don't want to hear they're not here,
but read their,
their,
their point of view and their line of thinking and how they came up with the
solutions.
And,
and that helps me when I read that helps me understand what would be like to
work with that person for real.
Um,
you know,
are they able to explain why they did what they did?
Are they glossing over a little details that actually matter?
Like what is it,
how do they,
how do they see their work and how do they write about it?
It's a very important part of,
of the job here at base camp.
So,
um,
yeah,
so writing is important in every position.
It doesn't matter what position you're in,
you still have to be a great writer.
We typically start by looking at the cover letter.
Um,
the,
the actual like work assignments to get hired here typically involve writing no
matter what,
what the position,
and I just think it's,
it's always proven in our case to be a really good indicator of someone's
success here whenever we've been,
so we hire someone where like,
ah,
I don't know,
there's just,
the writing wasn't quite right.
It almost always pans out that it turns out that they're not the right fit for
the company.
Even if their work was great,
but they're just unable to really convince people and persuade people based on
their sort of a,
a missing bit of,
it's not magic,
but I'll call it that in the writing or,
or where you read something about this is,
this is great.
I'd love to dig a little deeper on the example you gave with the design
finalists.
Let's say you're hiring for a position.
You have a handful of folks you've narrowed it down to and a,
you're paying,
you're going to pay each of them $1,500 for a one week project.
Do you assign them a project to give them a range of projects?
Can I love a little bit more in terms of specifics and then when you ask them
like why did you do what you did,
what you ended up doing,
do you provide them with guidelines for how to that or you keep it totally open
ended?
I'd love for you just to walk us through a hypothetical or real example of what
the project could look like and how it unfolds from there.
Yeah.
And the first,
first of all,
the reason why we do that is because you basically can't trust anyone's design
work in the past.
And the reason why is because a lot of people work with other people and you
don't really,
really know what they did.
Like you'll,
we'll get,
you know,
resumes like I did nike.com it's like,
no,
you didn't.
You worked on nike.com I can't tell what you did.
Exactly.
Um,
and so you'll see a lot of that.
Or you'll see people share screenshots with you of things and you're like,
you know,
I just don't know the process that went into that.
So it's hard for me to judge it.
It's not that I don't think that works good or bad,
it's a none of that.
It's like I just don't know what I'm evaluating here.
So the idea is that,
um,
once we get down to the five finalists,
after looking at work and looking at writing and the whole thing,
we feel these five people could be great fit for this particular position.
We give them all the same assignment.
And the assignment is sometimes there's actually a,
there's sometimes there is a choice like two or three different assignments,
but for the most part,
historically it's been one.
Lately we've been doing a few,
but it's been one
where everybody's who's applying for this job does the same project.
Everyone gets a week to do it.
They have to figure out how to fit that in and what their rest of their,
their day,
most people have jobs already so they've maybe have to work at night or whenever
they do it.
Um,
and we're,
we're,
you know,
I'm well aware of the fact that they don't have a lot of time,
so I'm not expecting perfection.
This is part of the reason why I look at the writing and the explanation of the
work because I recognize that,
you know,
who knows,
maybe you have a full time job,
maybe you have kids at home,
maybe you don't make whatever it is,
whatever it is.
Maybe you only have an hour a day to do this on the side and you're already
tired.
I get all of that.
So I'm more interested in the,
in you know,
how you approached the project and how you describe what you did and why you did
it.
Um,
so anyway,
they would do,
for example,
we take a screen from base camp and say,
um,
so to get really specific about this,
like,
uh,
here's the,
here's the way you add people to a base camp project.
Um,
what would you do to make this better?
Now you have no data.
You're not talking to anybody about it.
I just want to know what you would do.
Like,
what would,
what would you do?
Because a lot of the work at base camp is all based on what would you do?
We don't,
we don't do a lot of user testing.
We don't do,
we do use customer interviews and stuff,
but we don't get into a testing lab.
We don't watch people use our product.
We don't do any of that.
And we don't really look that much like usage data to really determine what
we're going to do.
So a lot of this is about gut and feel and what would you do?
What's wrong with the screen in your opinion?
And really interesting people's opinions.
I want people to have a point of view when I hire them.
I don't want people to say,
well,
I need this data and that data to make decisions.
I go,
yeah,
I get all that.
But what would you do?
I want to know what you,
I'm hiring you,
what would you do?
So anyway,
so they do the work and then,
um,
they,
uh,
present it and I say,
I say,
present it any way you want.
So there are no guidelines.
Um,
I just say present it any way you want,
but what I guess the one guideline is like,
I want to understand why you did what you did.
So some people present this work is like an elaborate website with a bunch of
different screens.
Some people present it as a pdf,
a static pdf,
some people write something up and sort of tell a linear story with screenshots
interspersed.
There's a variety of different ways people do it.
But ultimately I'm looking at the explanation of the work and the and the,
and the sort of the,
the,
the thought behind the ideas that are presented.
That's what I'm most curious about.
It's not necessarily whether or not the work is great because you're already a
finalist.
So I already know that you're capable of designing things.
Well,
what I want to make sure I understand is,
is where the ideas are coming from,
how they're filtering through your head,
how they're filtering through your fingers into the design itself.
Um,
and,
and why you did what you did and can you defend it.
One of the things is even when I disagree,
even when I should say,
even when I agree with the,
the the solution,
I'm,
I'm always going to push back on it,
um,
in these kind of situations because I want to see how people take criticism as
well.
That's a big part of this,
which is like constructive criticism and critique.
I want to see that.
One of the things we don't do and we don't believe in at all or like these
riddles and this bullshit tests crap,
right?
The Mckinsey,
how many golf balls can you fit into?
Seven 47 type stuff.
I said,
yeah,
the all like everything we tried to do it at base camp is about real stuff.
So like this is actually a real project that we would take on and it's not
bullshit and it's real.
So that's the getting riddles and stuff.
Forget it.
So real work.
I want to see how you'd explain it,
what you do with it,
why you do what you do with it,
and then I'm going to push back on it and see how you respond on it or responded
with it.
And that says a lot.
Um,
one of the designers we hired recently,
um,
for Ios,
Tara,
uh,
man is her name.
And,
and one of the things I was really impressed with when she delivered her project
and we start talking about it,
was that when we were going through it,
she goes,
you know,
I don't even know if I like what I did here.
And I loved that because that shows,
first of all,
a real sense of confidence in like talking to an employer.
And I don't even know if I liked what I did here.
Like that's most people are like,
this is the best thing in the world.
This isn't the best idea ever.
Like this is.
But then she's like,
you know,
I,
I think I like it but I'm not totally sure.
And I liked that and we dug into that and then we got into like,
why she didn't think it was great.
And that was just a very real conversation.
And I felt like I could work with someone like this.
Absolutely.
Because they're,
they don't think that everything they do,
it's going to be great.
And there,
there are self aware enough to recognize that and we can talk it through and
figure it out.
And that was,
that was a great thing.
So,
um,
there could have been,
for example,
in this case there weren't,
but there could have been five designers who are better than her visually
anyway.
I still would've gone with her because of her sort of her approach to the work
and her honesty about it.
That's what I'm looking for.
When I talked to somebody who I'm about to hire,
what would be an example of pushing back?
But let's just create a hypothetical or a real example and then what would a
trip,
the wire as far as red flags go or a positive indicators?
Sure.
So,
um,
I can't really,
it's hard to describe that particular project because we'd all have to be
looking at it to,
to point out that it could be anything.
I'm just wondering,
in other words,
this push back like,
wow,
I think this really sucks.
What say,
hmm.
Not sure how we feel about that,
or is it something else?
Yeah,
it's more,
it's more than obviously the latter.
I,
I remember say anything sucks.
Um,
I was using that just because of the rejection again.
Again.
Yeah,
you're totally right.
The,
the five five think,
dude,
it's more,
um,
you know,
I'm not sure that I see why,
you went down this road or um,
it doesn't,
this seem like a lot of steps or uh,
you know,
um,
this why,
you know,
this word save.
Maybe it should be preview.
Like why is it saved?
Like I kinda throw,
usually push backs with questions like I don't understand this or help me
understand this.
And that's kind of the,
the real one I like to use.
It was just like,
help.
I don't,
I'm not sure I get this.
Can you help me understand this?
Um,
but sometimes the red flags are very,
they're very clear.
It's the people hunched down into a defensive posture and,
and fight for their idea,
which is fine.
It's good to do that sometimes,
but not when it's like,
help me understand why,
you know,
why you went this direction.
It's like,
Oh,
you know,
I want the structure because I felt like it was the best possible thing.
Like there's some sort of what people get rushed about things.
I actually like when someone takes a pause and goes,
hmm,
let me think about that.
Well,
here's what I went through to get to here.
Like the reason I use the word say it was because,
uh,
you know,
this,
this reason or that reason or the reason I called it a draft and not a preview
is because of this and that I'm more interested in people retracing their steps
then then just sort of purely explaining there the outcome.
Um,
that's not really,
that's kind of a deeper thing,
but you'll see people in,
in designer views who get very defensive very quickly and they,
they,
you can tell that they're not listening anymore.
They're just,
um,
they're telling you what they want you to listen to instead of listening to what
you have to say.
That's very obvious.
And designer views when that comes up,
it's,
it's very clear.
So it's,
it's that I just fundamentally,
I'm looking for,
uh,
a deep degree of introspection and in the work and an understanding of how they
ended up there.
It's kind of like if you think about,
uh,
back in school where you,
your teacher would ask you to show the work when he did a math problem,
um,
with they're basically looking for is they're looking to see if you understand
how you came out with the answer versus like,
did you somehow memorize this or guests,
it's like,
or was it lucky or did you actually understand how you arrive there?
It's kind of the same thing.
I want people to show their work basically.
And that doesn't mean showing like all the drafts of the design work necessary.
It's not like going through previous versions.
It's again,
coming down to the,
the path that they took to land where they landed.
That's what I'm looking for.
Yeah,
that makes perfect sense.
And this is also,
um,
with the understanding that a
very different company from base camp,
but,
uh,
I've spent a lot of time with Matt Mullenweg of automatic,
which runs wordpress.com among other things.
And he values written communication exceptionally highly,
uh,
and,
and they do all their interviews via text and,
uh,
also have every,
at least for a long period up until maybe I wanna say at least 50 or a hundred
employees had every prospective employee knew they would have to spend.
And I don't know if this is part of the vetting process or post hiring a week or
two handling customer service.
Yup.
Uh,
and which also,
and not to say it's perfect for every company,
certainly,
uh,
but also tells you a lot more than just how they handle a user error.
Yeah.
Customer service situation.
Right.
If they refuse to do that,
what does that tell you?
Right.
If they do as great,
what does it tell you?
There's a lot more than just the words that come out of them.
Yeah.
And you know,
at our company,
everybody works customer service also.
So,
um,
no matter what position you're in,
every single person rotates one day through customer service,
every number of days.
Like we have 54 employees in the company,
about 15 or 16 on customer support.
So about 30 of us every 30 days.
We rotate through and do one day of customer service.
And that's the only reason why it's important for you to be able to write is
because,
um,
on that one day,
a month or one day every 40 days or whatever,
uh,
you are,
on the front lines,
speaking with customers and,
and empathizing with them,
understanding what,
what,
what they're dealing with.
Helping them understand what they don't understand,
helping us understand what we don't understand all of that stuff,
which is what customer service is it really all about.
Of course,
it's also about like troubleshooting and solving immediate problems.
But a lot of it too is,
is it's getting to the real like what,
what are they really asking for and why?
Uh,
and what are we doing wrong and what,
where our blind spots to all that stuff.
And a lot of that comes down to having a conversation with the customer and all
of our customer service has done the email or or or or Twitter or or chat or
something.
So we don't have a phone,
although we do do some phone support,
but we don't have a phone number that you can call in,
for example.
So it's all written.
So we want to make sure that if we're going to put someone in front of
customers,
they know how to write as well.
So that that is a big part of it too.
I didn't know that automatic did that as part as their part of their hiring
process,
but I love the idea.
Yeah,
it's a such a key,
such a key skill for so many reasons for people to want to become better writers
that are communicators.
Are there any books or resources,
exercises that you would recommend?
There is one of my favorite books is called revising prose and the cover is
horrible.
It's like,
ah,
that's how you can spot it,
right?
Yes.
It's like a CD rom and a pencil or something.
It's like,
what's,
I don't even understand how that happened.
Maybe they've revised it since,
but I think it's that bad still.
It's so horrible.
Anyway,
revising prose.
Thank God.
Thank God the title is so catchy.
Yeah,
exactly right.
Yeah.
Right.
But what's cool about it is that,
um,
and I forget the author and you,
you know,
you can look it up and put it the notes,
but um,
is that he dissects things one sentence at a time and his,
his ability to,
to take a sentence and cut it up and explain it and simplify it.
I think it's a wonderful skill and a great,
great book.
Uh,
so it's not really even about writing paragraphs or stories or how to organize
their an outline stuff.
It's like a sensor at a time and figuring how to structure things.
Love it.
Great Book.
And it's actually,
you know,
there's this class I've talked about before,
I've written a blog post about this class that I'd want to teach if I ever
taught a college class.
I think,
I think one of the biggest disservices that that,
that college does actually is that it doesn't teach people to write well.
Um,
in fact the teaches a lot of people,
especially in MBA programs to write very poorly.
So true.
It's so true.
And a lot of it's based on length,
like write a 10 page thing and or you know,
or whatever.
So the class I have always wanted to teach if I was ever to teach would be a
writing class.
I don't care what the subject is.
It doesn't matter.
Pick a subject and want you to write like a five page version of that article.
I want you to write a one page version of it.
I want you to write a five paragraph version,
a five sentence version in a one sentence version.
Um,
that's the assignment.
And we would do that over and over and over and over with different topics.
I don't care the topic,
it doesn't matter.
I just want you to be at a right at different levels of resolution and continue
to clarify it as you cut things out to the point where you can run it in one
sentence.
And of course there'll be more detail in the,
in the,
in the five paragraph version nine maybe it was three pages,
one page through paragraphs,
one sentence,
whatever it is.
But this,
this idea of going from writing the long piece and then cutting it down and
editing.
Editing is something that's rarely taught and really getting,
trying to hone in on what it is and realize like the,
the big idea here is that you can realize that so much of the stuff that you put
in a five page version,
it doesn't really matter that much.
And actually the one page version is probably better.
And maybe the,
the three paragraph version is much better than the one page version and you,
there's probably a point where you,
you,
you kinda lose it,
but it's still a great exercise.
So I,
I'd love to see that kind of writing instruction versus length,
which scent,
like long,
long things.
And then not actually editing.
This is the other thing that blows me away about education.
Um,
it's funny,
I was talking to my son's preschool and I was talking to the head of the school
about,
about this.
Um,
and the thing that's not taught in schools is iteration and iteration is
everything outside of school.
Um,
where you,
you do something and then like you,
you,
you know,
launch it or ship it whenever and then you're on to making a better version of
that thing pretty quickly.
In school we would always do something and sort of handed in and that assignment
would be done and then you go on and do another assignment.
You never get to revisit things.
Uh,
in the,
in the professional world you're revisiting things all the time.
And um,
I would love to see,
you know,
you hand something like this,
like this one page to,
to,
you know,
or five page to one page to five paragraphs,
whatever.
That's a version of a short term version of like revisioning in a sense that
perhaps the better way of doing that would be you firsthand.
And the five page version,
you get it back with notes,
then you're required to write the one page version of that.
Um,
but anyway,
the point is,
is that field to revisit something that you did and make it better and handed in
and revise it again at hand and revise it again.
Um,
is something that you don't see often.
Sometimes you see that with drafts in a,
in a document,
but it's not really quite the same as being able to come back to the idea.
So for example,
if you're doing something in school and you're building something or you're
doing a science project or whatever and you,
you do it and you're done,
you present it and it's over.
Like maybe a month later you're going to have a better idea for something that
you did and you go,
I want to do that again,
but schools and give you a chance to do anything again.
Really,
unless you like Ms,
you're stupid and you're held back and they say you can't go for further.
You know,
of course not stupid,
that's the wrong word.
But like the is like you're,
you know,
you didn't,
you didn't hit the criteria,
so we're going to let you do it again.
Like in some ways of course,
there's a lot of other reasons why this probably isn't necessarily a good thing
for people,
for,
for kids.
Um,
but uh,
to get a chance to do it all over again,
maybe you see it better the second time.
Um,
so anyway,
I would love to see revision and iteration built into education and this is sort
of writing assignment as sort of a way to get it done.
And I pulled up this book and the cover is truly awful.
Like what is the CD even doing there?
Uh,
on top?
How'd that happen?
Is it like clip art or something?
Like,
I don't even know how that happened that when they get to the bottom of that,
but revising prose Richard a Lanham.
Does that sound right?
I think so.
Yeah.
That's gotta be,
because the cover is this pen CD on top of a page with a bunch of markups on it.
Richard Aid,
Atlanta.
I'm another book that I found very helpful.
I haven't read it in a very long time,
but it's called simple and direct.
It should be fairly easy to write.
I don't remember the name of the author.
And,
uh,
I had the,
I had the great,
good fortune maybe to make too many modifiers on that,
but now that I'm thinking about writing the great good fortune of taking a class
in college,
I was at Princeton Undergrad with John McPhee,
who's a senior writer at the New Yorker.
It's one appeal to your or to at this point.
And the course was called the literature of fact.
It was about nonfiction writing,
creative nonfiction,
uh,
which doesn't mean making up 50%.
It means taking fact and leaving it into a narrative which John McPhee is
exceptionally good at.
And actually one book,
I think you would really enjoy this called draft number four,
which is about his writing process.
I think you'd be fascinated by it from a structural standpoint,
really fascinating.
And it gets into the weeds,
which is not for everybody,
but I think,
I think you'd appreciate it.
And,
uh,
I remember the first time it was,
the first time we had our writing assignments returned to us.
So every week we had a seminar,
a,
which was a 12 students or so we had to apply to get in a writing assignment and
then a one on one session with big fee to go over the writing assignment that he
had already marked up and given to us.
And I remember when he handed back the first writing assignment,
a man to all these students before he handed them out,
he said,
look,
he didn't say look,
cause that's not what he would say.
But he said,
he said,
I want you to know that you're all good writers.
You can,
all right,
so I don't want you to be intimidated by what I'm about to hand back and see.
It was a bad student by student.
The,
their faces drop.
And I got mine back and there was more red ink on the page then black ink.
But I typed out,
it really looked like there was more Reddick and it became so clear how
fuzzy.
So much of my thinking was how many unnecessary words there were,
how much gristle and fat there was in between the actual meat that was necessary
on the page.
And the reason I bring up this,
this,
this story is that over the course of the next few weeks,
as we were learning more,
practicing more and honing the sharpness of our writing,
getting progressively less red ink,
ideally my grades in all of my other classes went up.
And there was a very clear,
super clear correlation between cleaning up my thinking and everything else
running more smoothly.
It was really,
it could not have been more obvious and uh,
such a,
such an incredibly valuable skill.
It is.
You know,
something that I would also encourage people to do is to read Tom Petty lyrics.
Um,
it sounds,
but if you read Tom,
Tom Petty has such a wonderful efficiency in this storytelling and his lyrics
and um,
every word really counts and there's no filler.
It's any paints,
these really broad pictures with four or five words per,
per phrase and really,
truly is.
I thought one of the best,
I mean one of the best songwriters of course,
but really a great,
just a great writer in general when you read the lyrics.
So I would look at,
look at that and go look at the pictures he can paint and the emotions you can
evoke and the um,
the story he can tell with very few words.
He's extremely economical with his,
with his,
with his language or was,
and um,
it's a great thing to read.
So just go like,
like a stone of his albums.
Go look,
go look up the lyrics online and don't even listen to the songs,
but just read them and you go,
I see where he's going with this.
And it,
it's,
I always enjoy doing that from time to time.
He's just such a,
he was so good at that.
I will have to check that out.
Elmore Leonard,
also another fantastic one for people to look up and it makes me think you were
talking about the,
uh,
the one page three,
four,
five paragraph three,
paragraph,
one,
one line.
It makes me think of the,
the Hemingway story in one line,
which I'm sure I'm going to get slightly wrong,
but it was something,
right?
The,
uh,
used baby shoes never worn or I fucked it up.
The baby,
the baby shoes for sale,
baby shoes for sale,
never worn a,
the sort of five or six word story.
Uh,
it's,
it's a really valuable exercise.
Uh,
and,
and it's,
it's not just for academic purposes as you pointed out,
translates to everything.
No doubt.
Uh,
vintage watches.
God,
go,
tell me about,
tell me about the vintage watches
I'm into.
I'm into that.
Um,
I'm into vintage watches.
Let's see why.
Well,
first of all,
I'm into watches.
Um,
I'm into a lot of things that seem like there can only be one way to do it,
but there turns out there's a lot of ways.
So for example,
I love a chair does like designing chairs.
I don't design it myself and I love looking at chairs,
which are,
are,
are very simple things.
It's like,
you know,
you sit on them and that's what they do.
And you're like,
well,
there going to be a few ways to do a chair,
but turns out there's so many different ways to do a chair and it's really
interesting.
And watches are the same thing.
Vintage.
Do you have any favorite chairs?
Just as a side note?
Uh,
I,
I like a lot of,
uh,
stuff that she,
um,
his name is French so I'll probably get it wrong.
But gene,
Jean Pro Bay are,
uh,
from getting that right.
Um,
I love his designs,
his styles.
Um,
there's a bunch of others.
I'll maybe I'll send you an email afterwards to some of my favorite chair.
I'll send you some like,
sure.
Um,
but um,
I,
uh,
so watches are similar and that like a watch basically like,
look,
it's there to tell the time.
Some watches can do more than others,
but basically if they're wanting to tell the time and like,
okay,
there's,
you've got,
especially if you like an analog watches,
which is why one of the reasons I like vintage stuff cause it's like,
you know,
I ha a couple of hands,
three hands maybe or two hands and,
but there's so many different designs and so many different styles and so many
different elements and so many different approaches to it that there's an
endless amount of,
of curiosity in it for me.
Um,
and plus the cool thing about mechanical watches,
uh,
is that,
um,
they're such a,
it's a combination of all the things I like.
So it's design,
it's engineering,
it's materials,
it's,
it's like a Patina and like seeing age on things.
I love things that age well.
Um,
it's,
it's art,
it's science.
Like if you,
if you crack open one of these watches and look at the movement,
like there's serious engineering going on in there and some science,
material science and really fascinating stuff.
And like the idea that,
that mankind can capture time and tell it this way,
using springs.
And gears,
it's kind of an amazing thing and be that accurate.
So I've always sort of,
I haven't always been into them,
but my dad was into them still maybe still is.
I don't know if he collects stuff anymore,
but it used to when I was younger and I got into them.
Um,
and the vintage thing,
I'm actually kind of into vintage and modern these days,
but more so I find vintage and just more interesting because there's more
character in,
in,
in the objects because they have time on them.
It's actually have you know,
age on them and that's kind of cool to see how things age.
And that's one of the reasons why,
um,
like I like a lot of natural materials in general now we're like,
I'm branching into architecture discussion here,
but I like brick.
Uh,
I like wood.
I like things that,
that pickup age over time versus like,
um,
a lot of modern materials,
I feel like,
uh,
they don't age very well.
They look great when you do the photo shoot right afterwards built and then they
just age poorly and they show their age in a way that's not flattering,
but in fact it takes it to tracks from,
from the quality of the object.
So it's cool to see.
The other thing is I'll say about vintage watches is that it's really cool to
get to look down on your wrist and go,
this thing I have in my wrist has been working for 50 years and if someone looks
after it five more times over the next 50 years,
the next hundred years,
it'll still work.
There's basically nothing that is being created today or that is true anymore
except really watches mechanical watches.
Most other things these days are disposable and so it's kind of a great reminder
that you can actually build things that last and you can look down your risks
and go.
Someone else 50 years ago was looking down at the wrist seeing the exact same
thing and it worked just as well.
In 50 years from now,
my kid can look down on his wrist or her wrist and see the same thing I looked
at to tell the same amount of time and it's going to work as well.
And I just kind of love that idea.
So anyway,
that's sort of why I'm into it.
So a few things.
The first is at some point I need to introduce you to a Peter Attia MD.
He was a close friend of mine and a,
an extreme watch nerd.
Okay,
good.
I think you guys would have a lot to talk about if you could only pick and I'd
have no idea how many watches you have.
You don't have to divulge that.
But if you could only choose one to three watches to keep.
Okay.
Do any come to mind where you're like,
Yep,
these are definitely on the list?
Yes.
So,
uh,
I have a,
it's called a Rolex Milgauss six,
five,
four one is the model number,
what they would call the reference number in the watch world.
It's from 1958.
Okay.
And I just think it's the coolest fucking thing ever.
So I just love the way it looks.
So cool looking.
It's,
it's,
it's awesome.
So anyway,
Rolex Milgauss six,
five,
four,
one from 1958.
Um,
that's,
that's definitely one keeper.
Um,
I have like an old protec Felipe,
uh,
blanking on the reference right now.
Um,
it's,
it was,
it was built for,
um,
similar to this Milgauss I was telling you about.
Oh,
in Milgauss means 1000 gallons.
So it was a,
it was a,
it was a watch built for scientists who worked in high magnetic environments and
watches,
typically benches one,
especially now,
modern ones were a little bit different,
but,
um,
they don't work well in magnetic environments because the spring that's inside
them,
once it's magnetized,
it can't tell time properly anymore,
basically.
So,
so these watches were built for scientists to be a magnetic or anti magnetic.
And so the Milgauss was one of them.
And then,
and then protec made one car.
I can't believe,
I can't remember the reference right now.
Anyway,
you can say that.
You can send it with your links to the chairs.
I'll send it exactly.
Also an anti magnetic watch.
Um,
and it was sort of their answer to the Milgauss.
So it's funny that like the two things come to mind immediately are like watches
for scientists,
which you know,
is just what a cool niche.
Um,
you know,
to make,
make a product for scientists in the fifties,
like how cool.
Like kind of,
if you can imagine scientists in the fifties what their white coats and like
learning all sorts of new things about physics in the world and biology,
uh,
and all sorts of really cool stuff happened back then.
Um,
that those are the two watches that immediately come to mind that I really,
really dig.
Um,
there,
there's another one,
um,
actually,
which is a,
I'm gonna get this name wrong too,
so I'm just going to call it,
it's [inaudible] cult or [inaudible] or something on that.
I can never,
I never exactly know what it is.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
it's called the Polaris from 1968.
It's a dive watch built for divers and it has an alarm on it.
I'm a mechanical alarm,
which is really cool and really unique and rare,
especially at the time,
which I think is really beautiful and just a really neat complication for a
mechanical watch should have an alarm on it.
Um,
so you could say like for example,
at five o'clock I want this thing to buzz very loudly,
so I would know that it's five o'clock,
which of course it's so silly and easy to do with an iPhone or any digital
thing,
but mechanically it's actually,
it was quite a challenge and very few watches I've ever had a mechanical alarm.
I also like the way it looks.
So anyway,
there's some of that stuff that I'm in too.
There's other bunch of other things.
Um,
but those are the kind of the three that the initially come to mind as ones that
I'm really into.
If you had to give a Ted talk on obsessions and it couldn't be related to your
company,
it couldn't be related to watches this as these are personal obsessions,
what,
what might you talk about that,
that a lot of people wouldn't know about?
Well,
I don't know if I'd be able to talk about it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm imagining all of the,
the,
uh,
unacceptable,
socially awkward sexual fetishes that you wouldn't be able to talk about on the
Ted Stage,
but continue,
I guess I didn't finish the sentence and I said maybe I wouldn't be talk
about it with authority,
let's say.
So let's say I'm,
one of the things that I'm really into strangely is,
is prairie restoration.
Okay.
So stand back here for a second.
Let me fill you in on this.
So I,
maybe 10 years ago I bought a farm up in a rural Wisconsin about three hours
from Chicago where I live.
It's like 50 miles west of Madison,
Wisconsin.
For those who kind of know the geography and it's a very rural and it's kind of
hilly.
It's very beautiful.
I bought it.
And,
um,
I always wanted some land.
I love nature.
I love just getting out and walking in nature,
just to me the most refreshing thing you could ever do.
Um,
and uh,
so I bought this land and I looked at it and I thought it was just beautiful.
And amazing and it was,
but I learned a couple of years in that was full of weeds and invasive species
and like not really the way it should be a or shoot or was,
but modern farming and,
and,
and the,
the fact the land's been tilled a bunch of times and there's invasive species
and stuff.
It's sort of took over the land.
So I got on this kick to,
to,
to find a prairie restoration specialists,
which I learned that there's this thing called prairie restoration where you
could sort of bring the land back to the way it was to prairie in this
particular part of the country.
And the prairie is in fact the,
um,
the most endangered natural habitat in the United States.
There's only like something like a thousand or something acres left of it in the
entire United States.
So people talk about old growth forests being gone and stuff.
There's actually more old growth forest United States and there's prairie
prairie's gone basically.
But I,
I visited some actual prairies that have been restored and also some,
some that are still around and they're just,
you're due to agriculture I assume,
or farming.
Yeah,
like a peep,
you know,
all the land has been tilled basically for farmland.
Um,
and,
um,
and I visited some of these prayers and they just are the most beautiful thing,
uh,
hundreds of species of plants and flowers and,
and,
and shrubs and insects and birds.
And it's just these,
this beautiful,
beautiful,
beautiful thing.
And so I have this land that's quite a bit of acreage.
And I,
and I started hiring,
I hired this guy to,
to help me restore it.
And we've been doing it for seven,
eight years now or something,
bringing the land back to the way it was like five acres at a time.
Um,
and planting native species and,
and uh,
and getting rid of all the invasives and also doing the same thing.
There's some force on the,
on the property.
And I'm doing oak savanna restoration.
So a lot of invasive trees have grown up around these big,
huge,
beautiful oak trees that are hundreds of years old,
but they've been crowded by these other trees are getting rid of some of the
other trees and letting the oak speed the way they were.
And then returning the fourth floor of the way it was.
And it's just such an incredibly rewarding but super slow process.
It takes like you see these prairies,
if first of all you have to like kind of get rid of everything that's there and
then weeds pop up.
You have to get rid of everything that's there.
Cause there's what's called a seed bank in the soil.
So the seed bank is basically hundreds of years worth of seeds that have just
been waiting to sprout.
And so you have to kind of like,
you clear out all the living stuff and then like there's all these seeds that
are then now we'll expose to the sunlight and then they sprout.
And you have to basically just kind of nuke all for a while until there's
nothing basic left in the soil.
Um,
or invasive species left in the soil,
and then he can go and get native species by actually doing seed gathering.
You can gather seeds,
it's certain prairie's or you can buy seeds,
native seeds.
You can also find individual prairie plants in what's called prayer remnants,
which are like small vestiges of old prairie that might still be on your
property and harvest the seeds from those as it's really,
really slow,
amazing thing.
Then you seed it and then it might take five or six years for a prayer to grow
because the prairie plants typically invested all their energy in the first few
years in the,
in the roots.
So you don't see anything growing.
It's really frustrating.
It looks like shit for a long time and all of a sudden it starts to come up and
then it's just so rewarding.
It's so wonderful to walk through.
And um,
so that's something that I'm really into in a deep way.
And uh,
probably most people don't know about it in general.
I didn't know about it until a few years ago,
but I love it so much and I'm kind of on this crusade now to like this anti corn
crusade.
You know,
I want to basically whenever land comes up next to my land,
I want to buy it because most of it's corn and corn is sort of at the root of a
lot of different problems.
Uh,
and I just want to like get rid of the corn.
It returned the land of the way it was and sort of create this patchwork of land
and then eventually put it in some sort of trust so it can never be touched in.
There can always be these,
these beautiful tracks of land forever.
Uh,
of course they'd have to be maintained and now to have to be how the trust would
have to be able to figure that out.
Maybe part of it is farm to,
to fund that.
But anyway,
that's something that I would probably love to talk about,
although I don't know enough about it to do.
You have a Ted talk,
but I can certainly talk someone's ear off for about an hour on all the little
details that I've learned.
What a fantastic project.
It's such a fun thing that sounds therapeutic to in in the sense that
having to embrace slowness in at least one compartment of your life seems to be
a nice counterbalance to potentially external or internal drives,
not necessarily in you,
but in a lot of people,
certainly myself included at times to do bigger things faster.
Right.
No doubt.
And the other thing about that I'll say is that you can't even speed this
process up if he wanted to.
And that's what's so awesome about it.
And by the way,
the process is multilevel,
multilayered in multi-tiered.
And probably by this point you're like,
I should never have asked him this question
anyway.
Uh,
real quick.
Um,
what's cool about it too is knowing to the plants,
like new plans come up and,
and all sorts of species blue,
but you start to see new insects and new insects come a few years later and
they,
they just,
somehow you're like,
where'd they come from?
And like they're still out there but they find it and they,
and they,
and they're there,
they're wired to proliferate and these environments and then you see new birds
and new bird species.
So there's like a hundred and something bird species.
Now on my property,
when originally there weren't,
there was like 40 and you're like where'd they come from?
And they just come from,
they find it somehow and they come in and then like here's the thing I've been
learning is if you build upon,
for example,
I don't have any pond but I have a river,
but if there's a pond,
if you just feel upon with water within a few years you will have fish.
And you're like,
what?
How does that happen?
Like how could that possibly be?
And it turns out like fish are,
you know,
a bird might be eating a fish and drop it before it's dead and it pops in the,
into there.
And that could have been a pregnant fish.
And before you know it,
like the whole thing is like life.
It's just waiting for souls.
Not Waiting,
it's everywhere.
But like,
if you restore property,
you restore some,
some,
some land and give it some space and let it do what it does.
Nature is so,
so resilient and just wants to thrive and it's so cool to watch it happen on its
own schedule and say nature is in never.
It's never in a hurry.
That's the thing that I love so much about it is that it's never in a hurry,
but it accomplishes everything.
And that's a quote that I read somewhere and I don't know where I read it,
who said it,
but I love it and I always think about it,
which is that it'll take its time and it'll get it wherever it needs to get done
done.
And however long it takes,
it takes,
um,
which is such an analog or such an opposite in an analog and opposite to
humanity,
which is always rushing,
which is actually typically destroying,
um,
and which is getting faster and faster and faster.
And I don't think it's the right path,
but it is what it is.
Thank you for sharing.
I love that.
It also makes me think about how much of life is setting the conditions for good
things to happen,
not trying to force good things.
And,
and uh,
to give another example that,
uh,
the kind of bio hacker slash nutrition crowd might be interested in is the
contrast between probiotics where you're say swallowing bacteria you hope will
take root in your gut among other things,
right?
Which often does not work very well.
Uh,
con contrasted with prebiotics where you're consuming different types of food
stuffs could be certain types of fiber,
Baobab route for instance,
which is effectively,
this is very simplified,
but restoring the soil conditions in your gut so that the types of bacteria you
want to grow naturally begin to take root and grow.
And you can't just take a handful of seeds and like drive them into the ground,
expecting them to pop out overnight.
It just doesn't,
it doesn't work that way.
And so thinking about setting the conditions is something I've been thinking a
lot about setting the conditions for positive emergent properties.
And then secondly,
you know,
it's just think about this today because I was watching a documentary last night
where this mother was giving her some advice and she said,
I just want you to learn patience.
You need to learn patience patients.
And you,
I've been seeing,
I thought over the years a lot about this word and whether I need more or less
patients.
And I was thinking today that it's maybe it's unproductive to think of it in
terms of more or less patients,
but rather in terms of developing the ability to discern between the things that
can and should be accelerated and the things that can't be accelerated.
And if you attempt to accelerate then we'll just do more damage.
It's to that,
I mean,
I love this idea that you're bringing up about,
about probiotics versus um,
prebiotics and creating the conditions for growth or creating conditions for
desired outcomes or whatever.
And I'm going to tie it all back.
I mean,
we're tying this,
like I'll let me tie like prairie restoration to business building,
which is,
um,
and,
and gut building basically.
And,
and you know,
that gut health.
And the whole thing,
which is that part of the two is,
is not only creating the conditions for things to thrive,
but also not creating conditions for certain things to thrive.
So,
um,
something,
for example,
our business is self funded.
Yeah,
we did take money from Bayzos in 2006 but that was a personal founder shares.
None of that is money.
Everyone knew our business.
David and I took some money off the table.
So we've been 100% bootstrapped and funded by customers ever since day one,
which means we've created a situation where we don't have to answer to anybody,
we don't have to be in anyone else's timescale.
Um,
I don't have to build something that I know is going to have to be sold in seven
years because the fund is coming due and like they need their money out of it.
Or I also don't have to build something that grows at a certain rate because you
know,
you need to grow at a certain rate for a certain return.
We don't care about returns are the conditions we've set are not to have returns
thrive.
And,
and you know,
generally it turns for others.
But actually what we've tried to set up his profit conditions for profitability
and for sustainability because as long as we make more money than we spend,
we can exist for as long as we want.
There's no external,
um,
pressures,
artificial pressures that we've set up or conditions that we've created that
will force us to make a decision about when we have to sell the business at some
point.
So it's not only about creating conditions for thriving,
it's about like,
in fact putting up barriers for certain things not to happen.
And I've been thinking a lot personally about putting a lot of,
I've been putting a lot of energy into making sure certain things don't happen
versus putting energy in to make sure certain things do happen.
And,
uh,
I think if you can prevent a lot of things from happening by thinking about what
you don't want,
you do create the conditions then for other things to come in,
which are the things that you actually do want.
So,
um,
I,
I think there's a lot of similarities here between nature and business.
And,
and you know,
gut health is nature as well of course,
and and conditions and letting things sort of thrive and preventing other things
from happening.
I mean,
it's cool.
Like for example,
we have hundreds over a hundred species of birds now on the property.
We didn't put bird seed out.
Like,
you know,
you don't put bird seed out.
What you do is you put seed out that grows in the ground that then creates the
conditions or actually it grows seed.
So it does actually grow bird seed,
right?
It grows bird seed,
it just takes five years and then birds find it and they're like,
everything just happens the way it naturally should at the right pace and the
right scale.
And it's just very rewarding to to see that happening.
And I think it does color your impression of other things and sort of shows you
in many ways how sort of silly speed is in a lot of other things where it's
injected unnecessarily in,
in sort of the damage that it does.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's a topic we could go on and on with for for hours.
I'm sure.
So maybe we should do that at some point.
But,
uh,
let me wrap up with just a,
just a few more questions and one,
one of them I've asked you before,
uh,
and this will sound familiar and then I'll,
I'll pause for a second by little time.
But if you could have a giant billboard anywhere with anything on it,
what would it say and why?
Right.
It could be a quote,
could be a word,
could be a question,
could be anything.
It could be someone else's quote.
Now I asked you this question in tribe of mentors and you gay,
you see one of these quotes and you gave about out of 15 to 20,
maybe more,
25,
fantastic quotes.
I mean,
these are,
these are excellent quotes,
but right now in your life,
it doesn't have to relate to anything in the external,
wider world.
Uh,
uh,
let me,
let me read a few just to give people a taste.
And then I'd love to know which one you would pick.
Sure.
Right now in your life,
but,
well,
let me pick a few here.
If you think you're too small to be effective,
you've never been in the dark with a mosquito.
Betty Reese,
every great Cosby begins as a movement,
becomes a business and eventually degenerates into a racket.
Eric Hoffer,
uh,
this one has proven very popular.
The fairest rules are those two,
which everyone would agree if they did not know how much power they would have.
John Rawls,
and I'll read,
I'll read one more since we've mentioned him a few times.
Prices.
What you pay value is what you get more in.
Lafitte.
Uh,
where,
where would you go at this point in your life with a message,
a word,
a quote,
a question,
anything on a gigantic billboard,
metaphorically of course,
getting a message out to millions or billions of people.
Yeah.
Um,
well I think it'd be fun just to say the word billboard on a billboard and just
leave.
Pay for it.
Pay for it for a hundred years.
And there it is,
it's called billboard,
but it would be kind of fun,
but also a gag.
Um,
I liked that,
that John Rawls quote so much,
which is a,
the Ferris rules are the ones you would,
I forget.
Yeah,
agreed.
Yeah.
The Ferris rules of those two,
which everyone would agree if they did not know how much power they would have.
Yeah.
I,
that to me is at the root of so many things.
Um,
we've been dealing with a little bit of this in our,
in our own business.
Uh,
it's a little bit slightly different,
but just like information asymmetry and recognizing that everybody has the same
information.
So they look at things through different lenses and it's very important to
recognize the fact that you can't just come at something one way because you
know it,
if someone else doesn't know it,
you can't assume that they knew that.
And you know,
there's,
it's the same sort of idea which is,
which is,
um,
uh,
you,
you almost,
you can't be upset when someone has a PR,
a reaction to something when they just have a different set of information.
And similarly,
you know,
um,
uh,
you,
the rules are,
are,
you know,
rules are based on like who has the power to make them basically today.
That's kind of how it is in almost everything.
Um,
and so it's a good reminder that um,
rules basically are the Ferris to those who make them unfortunately,
but they would be the fairest if no one knew who they applied to.
And it just a good reminder and a lot of different levels.
It's one of my favorite quotes and I think that's probably something I would put
up on a billboard.
It'd be hard to read at 70 miles an hour to speed by it,
which is why I still like billboard.
But um,
as a quote,
I think it's the most meaningful,
one of the most meaningful quotes and most important quotes to,
to keep in mind whatever it is that you do.
Definitely.
And I'll read,
I'll read one more just because actually every two more of your quotes because
there are many to choose from.
Uh,
here's one that applies certainly to a few things.
We've talked about the conversation quote,
not everything that can be counted counts and not everything that counts can be
counted.
William,
Bruce Cameron,
and then the next,
and the last one I'll read is by Albert Schweitzer in the hopes of reaching the
moon.
Men fail to see the flowers at Lawson at their feet.
And I've got a story,
but maybe for another time about that quote.
Well,
I can tell you now.
Let's do it.
Let's just get into it.
Sure.
So,
um,
I don't know.
A number of years ago I was invited to,
to go to this,
uh,
John Maeda invited me to go to this thing,
um,
at the,
at the glass house in new Canaan,
Connecticut.
I think it is,
um,
the Philip Johnson Glass House.
And it was a like a summit on simplicity and there was I think 10 or 15 people
invited.
And um,
uh,
one of the people invited was,
it was this older man,
Japanese man,
I think he was in his eighties or close to it.
Almost everyone else was as much younger,
much,
much younger.
20s and 30s.
Forties maybe.
Um,
and like I said earlier,
I love,
oh I love older people so I sort of gravitated to him.
He was really well dressed and just,
it seemed interesting and um,
I noticed that he was,
um,
whenever we were going.
So the Philip Johnson Glass House,
the whole campus I think is about 50 acres and there's maybe a dozen different
buildings and it's kind of a neat idea because Philip Johnson had this idea that
it's actually one building and the hallways or just outside,
um,
which is kind of a cool thought.
Um,
but really it's like 12 different buildings.
Like for example is all,
he has an office which was a separate building,
which doesn't have a bathroom,
doesn't have plumbing because he didn't need it cause it's like it's still part
of the house that has plumbing.
I just have to walk outside to get there.
Anyway,
we were walking between these houses and you have a 50 acre site,
so there's a bit of distance between these buildings.
And I noticed that this guy was always last in the line to walk and I kinda sat
back with him on,
on one of the walks and,
and,
you know,
but he was also like,
it wasn't because he was old and that would be the first thing you would think
that he's just older,
so he's going to walk slower.
But actually he's like,
no.
And I could tell that he was physically able to walk as fast as everybody else.
It wasn't that he goes,
you know,
everyone's just walking too fast and they're missing things as they go.
Um,
he was so,
he just kneel down and he looked,
he took like this square foot of ground.
And,
um,
uh,
and by the way,
I had noticed as he was walking,
he was looking down as well.
So he's walking slowly and looking down and he,
he just,
he kind of took the square foot of,
of,
of land and like pointed out some flowers and some insects and some shapes and
some stuff and says like,
this is beautiful.
People feel like they have to go all over the world to see something new.
All they have to do is look down.
Um,
and if you walk slowly and looked down like there's a world under your feet all
the time,
an interesting world.
And he goes,
these people ahead of me,
they're younger.
Yeah,
maybe they can walk a bit faster,
but look at everything they're missing.
Uh,
and I just,
that really just kind of totally smacked me in the face.
I love this point.
Like,
yeah,
they're going faster and they look like they're going somewhere but look at
everything and they're missing along the way.
And so,
uh,
that,
point about that other quote that you just brought up about going to the moon,
missing the flowers,
like that's sort of similar thing,
which is,
you know,
especially today where everyone's rushing all over the place trying to get
somewhere and you're like,
where are you actually going and what are you actually missing?
And I thought that that,
that moment,
this guy actually stopping and physically explain that to me and looking down
and pointing out some things.
It was a really poignant thing and it's something I always have always
remembered since then.
What a lovely story.
He's a lovely man.
I think he's still around.
I'm sure you that from my understanding is he's a Japanese garden expert.
He has an amazing Japanese garden apparently in his backyard somewhere in
northern California.
Uh,
and he's also like a wine connoisseur and supposed to be a really fascinating
guy.
I never really caught up with them afterwards.
I always meant to and I,
I missed that opportunity and I should probably figure out how to get touch with
them,
but wonderful man,
really interesting person and I appreciate the lesson he taught me there.
Let me track him down and let me know.
It sounds like maybe the type of person I got hot gas.
Yeah,
definitely someone who can really embrace the,
the joy of missing out.
Yeah.
Shit.
Uh,
Jason will,
this has been so much fun.
I really appreciate you taking the time today to chat with me and share your
stories with the world also.
Well thanks for having me.
This is super fun.
It's always fun to talk to you and thanks for giving me so much time to do that.
My pleasure.
And is there,
is there anything else before we wrap up that you would like to ask of the
audience,
suggest to the audience?
Any closing comments of any type?
Nope.
I don't have any,
actually.
I like answering questions so I don't,
I don't have any proclamations or anything to,
to share,
so I don't,
um,
if anyone wants to,
to get in touch,
I think you'll have some of that stuff.
So feel free to hit me up on Twitter or wherever.
Oh,
the other thing actually I will mention,
um,
David and id chase and I are doing this new a youtube channel,
which is kind of a,
something that people have been asking for for a while.
We're calling it getting real and we're basically showing what are like,
kind of like you asked me like,
what's your day like,
what do you,
people always like,
what's your morning like and what,
what,
what do you do?
I'm like,
well,
why don't I just show you?
So,
um,
we're doing these videos of actually walking through code samples,
walking through design decisions through design reviews and making them all
public.
So I think it's kind of a neat thing to,
to check out if you're interested in sort of how we look at design and how we
look at Code and how we look at writing.
One of the things actually did was I wrote an article for ink recently and I
just recorded my screen and sort of talked out loud as I was writing it to sort
of show like here's how I read an article.
I don't start with an outline and you start with a blank sheet.
I got Kinda just right.
And then I was sort of doing the director's cut is I went and editing is editing
live as I wanted to know,
sort of a fun sort of thing.
Um,
so I'm doing some of that which should be kind of fun to follow.
People are interested in that.
Um,
other than that,
everything else to,
to share.
You've written a lot and do you have many popular articles,
essays,
blog posts,
et cetera,
online.
If someone wanted to start with one or two,
are there one or two that you could mention as a gateway drug into the mind of
Jason?
Well speaking,
based on our conversation today,
there was this article I wrote about like I've never had a goal a which should
be a good thing to start reading.
I think that would are a good place to read.
I think probably it's on,
it's on our blog signal versus noise,
which is on medium.
If you searched for my name on Google and say never had a goal,
you'll probably,
yeah,
I try be a good
Jason freed.
Never had a goal,
they'd probably be a good one to read.
And then,
um,
uh,
I also wrote one about not having expectations,
which might be another interesting thing to look at.
Um,
if there's any other ones,
I'll,
uh,
I mean there,
there are some other ones,
but I'm not sure if they'd be good places to start,
but those might be a good place to start.
Great.
And I'll,
uh,
I'll include chairs,
maybe prairie restoration,
uh,
the Polaris Watch,
I'll send you all that stuff.
We'll include all of that in the show notes.
So for people listening,
you'll be able to find all of that at tim.blog/podcast and just search Jason and
it'll pop right up and you can find all of these links and more as well as every
other episode.
And,
uh,
Jason at some point,
maybe we'll do a round two and it'd be lovely to see you in person sometime.
Yeah.
You're down.
Where are you now?
I'm in Austin,
Texas.
Austin.
Okay.
Well,
uh,
at some point,
yeah,
we'll run into each other again,
but I'd love to do it again and if we want to do it in person,
that'd be even better.
So let me know.
I'm around.
Definitely.
Yeah.
You know,
Austin,
Texas,
it's the third coast as they say.
He said that about Chicago,
I think every,
every other places.
This is the third coast.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Need water to be a coast.
I mean,
at least we have lakes.
We do have some creaks.
Uh,
we're not returning entirely dry.
There are rivers,
so we do what we do have that.
Uh,
but to be continued and to everyone out there on the interwebs and beyond.
As always,
thank you for listening.
Be Safe or not and
pay attention to what's under your feet.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
You enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday.
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one and if you sign
up,
I hope you enjoyed.
This episode is brought to you by wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my goto platform,
blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for everything every day.
My site tim.blog is built on it.
The websites for my books,
including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors,
all in wordpress.com and the founder Matt Mullenweg wouldn't have close friends,
has appeared on this show many times.
The search,
Matt Mullenweg Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a personal blog,
a business site,
or both,
you can make a really big impact right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good company.
It's used by the New Yorker,
Jay Z,
Beyonce,
five 38 tech crunch,
Ted,
CNN,
and time just to name a handful,
and one of my friends at Google shall remain nameless,
has told me that wordpress.com offers the best out of the box SEO imaginable
input.
It's one of the many reasons that nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of designs and templates that you can use,
and it's easy to get started.
There's no need to worry about security upgrades,
posting any of that debt for 24 seven support.
And they're very,
very responsive questions to here,
right back to you.
And this allows you to create the highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction.
So if you're building a website period,
and my friends come to me and ask what I use,
what I recommend they use,
the answer is wordpress.com to check it out.
Do you want to get started today?
Learn more with a 15% discount off any new plan.
Go to wordpress dot pump old sessions him.
Create your website and find the friends like for you to learn more.
Take a look.
wordpress.com four slash 10 15% off the brand.
What's check it out.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike and the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose,
I've known him forever,
some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him as a dude,
you look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing peloton five days a week.
Now that caught my attention because Kevin does nothing five days a week and you
know,
I love you Kevin,
but it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually,
but peloton is an indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting classes into your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute,
etc.
New classes are added every day and this includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes taught by the world's best instructors or
find her own favorite class on demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do live
classes and you can compete with your friends which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like not Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions that are shorter like 20 minutes and I think
Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone seems to have their favorite instructor or
you can select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that that along with the realtime leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller than you'd expect so it can fit in a
living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet and believe it or not and it fits with no
problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you might say Matt accessories,
wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and those are in the accessory category.
So this hundred dollars off is a very legit,
$100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else,
or are you just want to get a fantastic gift for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories,
including the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code.
Tim.